bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte
c'est le nombre de jours pendant
lesquels notre compatriote le
journaliste Olivier Dubois a été retenu
au Tage
je vous remercie il a été retenu au Tage
après avoir été kidnappé le 8 avril 2021
à Gao dans le nord du Mali par le groupe
de soutien à l'Islam et aux musulmans
principal alliance djihadiste au Sahel
lié à Al-Qaïda il est aujourd'hui libre
pour lui pour ses confrères pour notre
pays et pour ses valeurs universelles
c'est une nouvelle qui nous réjouit tous
l'Assemblée nationale salut l'action de
ceux qui ont contribué à cette
libération et se félicite de son retour
dans les prochaines heures sur le sol
français et je voudrais que nous lui
disions ensemble notre soulagement et la
joie que nous avons de le retrouver
parmi merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
donc l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion commune et les votes sur la
motion de censure déposée en application
d'articles 49 à Linéa 3 de la
Constitution par Monsieur Bertrand
penchet et 90 membres de l'Assemblée
d'une part et par Madame Marine Le Pen
et 87 membres de l'Assemblée d'autre
part la première ministre ayant engagé
la responsabilité de son gouvernement
sur l'adoption du projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 compte tenu du texte
de la commission mixte paritaire
modifiée par l'amendement déposé par le
Gouvernement
j'appelle Monsieur Charles de Courson
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente Madame la Premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres madame la Présidente de la
Commission madame la rapporteur général
mes chers collègues
le groupe liote a pris l'initiative de
cette notion de censure parce que nous
défendons plusieurs valeurs qui sont
attaquées par ce texte sur les retraites
nous défendons une nation française
décentralisée politiquement mais aussi
socialement
nous défendons une société solidaire qui
aide chaque citoyen trouver sa place une
république sociale telle qu'elle est
inscrite dans notre constitution nous
défendons aussi une société libre qui
permet à chacun de choisir sa vie y
compris le moment de sa retraite
au début de l'examen du projet de loi
sur les retraites nous avons parlé de
déni de démocratie depuis le
gouvernement a usé de toutes les
manœuvres possibles pour contourner et
contraindre le débat parlementaire pour
tordre des procédures
l'Assemblée nationale seule
représentante du peuple français n'aura
jamais voté sur ce projet de loi qui
cristallise les tensions les inquiétudes
et la colère de nos concitoyens
je veux
je veux insister sur la gravité de cet
instant
notre décision de déposer une motion de
censure n'a pas été prise à la légère
notez gros vous avez mis en garde contre
la tentation de passage en force
dès l'automne nous avons appelé à de
vrais négociations avec les partenaires
sociaux nous avons appelé à une grande
conférence sociale sur le travail et le
financement du système de retraite nous
avons toujours joué le jeu de l'écoute
et du dialogue nos deux groupes n'a
d'ailleurs pas voté jusqu'à ce jour les
précédentes notions de censure
nous avons pris tout notre part pour
éviter de fracturer notre pays plus qui
ne l'est déjà
mais ce texte a marqué la mort des
engagements pris en juillet dernier
madame la Première ministre relire
aujourd'hui votre discours de politique
générale est cruel je vous cite nous
mènerons pour chaque sujet une
concertation dense nous aborderons
chaque texte dans un esprit de dialogue
de compromis et d'ouverture et bien vous
avez échoué à rassembler vous avez
échoué à convaincre alors vous avez cédé
à la facilité et éviter la sanction du
vote
d'autant qu'en réalité rien ne vous
obligeait 49-3 le courage le respect des
institutions le respect de vos
engagements aurait dit conduire au vote
nous voulions voter même les groupes de
la majorité voulaient voter ce vote vous
l'auriez très probablement perdu mais
c'est la règle en démocratie
madame la Première ministre vous avez
décidé d'engager votre responsabilité et
bien nous nous avons décidé de prendre
les nôtres avec cette notion de ceinture
et pour déposer nous avons reçu le
concours de nombreux députés d'autres
groupes politiques et je tiens ici à
tous les remercier
nous avons déposé cette notion de
censure car vous avez clairement
détourné l'esprit de la Constitution
vous avez fait le choix tout d'abord de
recourir à cette fausse loi de
financement rectificative de la sécurité
sociale dès janvier alors même que la
loi initiale était à peine votée
la note du Conseil d'État ne nous a pas
été transmise nous savons que certains
des articles du texte sont de véritables
cavaliers sociaux c'est le cas notamment
de l'index senior de dispositions
relatives à la pénibilité ou à l'agir
Arco
ce que je dis ici n'est ni anecdotique
ni technique vous avez délibérément
choisi cette procédure pour préparer un
éventuel passage en force une procédure
qui facilite le recours à 11e 49-3 en un
an une procédure qui encadre et
contraint les délais d'examen rendant
impossible tout débat serein et
approfondi résultat l'Assemblée
nationale a examiné que deux articles
elle a d'ailleurs à une large majorité
rejetée d'articles 2 malgré tout
transmis au Sénat par le gouvernement
au Sénat justement vous avez fait le
choix de recourir au vote bloquées du
44.3 pour écourter les débats et tout
cela pour infiner nous priver d'un vote
sur le texte issu de la CMP comment
accepter un tel mépris du Parlement
comment accepter de telles conditions
d'examens sur un texte qui aura des
incidences durables sur la vie de
millions de nos compatriotes
si notre notion
si notre notion venait à être rejetée
nous usurions de toute dernière arme le
recours au Conseil constitutionnel
celui-là tranchera en droit et de nous
promettre je le cite
par ailleurs vous rappeler que ce projet
de réforme des retraites n'a pas de
délégitimité démocratique contrairement
à ce que dit le président de la
République les Français ne l'ont pas élu
pour repousser à 64 ou 65 ans l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite beaucoup
d'entre nous ont voté pour lui au second
tour par défaut
quant aux élections législatives au
premier tour seul 13% du corps électoral
ont voté pour des candidats soutenus par
le Président de la République et au
second tour vous n'avez obtenu que 250
sièges pour former ici une minorité
présidentielle
alors alors qu'il fallait un vrai
dialogue avec les forces politiques et
les partenaires sociaux vous n'avez
proposé aux organisations syndicales
qu'un semblant de concertation ajoutant
au déni de démocratie politique indéni
de démocratie sociale
le président Macron après sa réélection
reconnaissait que je cite nombre de
Français avez voté pour lui non pour son
programme mais pour faire bourrage à
l'extrême droite et de nous promettre je
le cite j'ai conscience que ce vote
m'oblige pour les années à venir qui
est-il advenu de cette promesse monsieur
le président
qu'en est-il du fond de cette réforme
rappelons que ce projet de loi a été
vendu autour de deux arguments la
justice sociale et le financement
durable de notre système de retraite
votre premier argument ne tient pas vous
le savez au fond de vous le recul de
l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans cristallise
en réalité tout est injustices les 17,7
milliards d'euros d'économies attendus
sont essentiellement portés par les plus
modestes il porte sur ceux qui auront à
travailler plus sans voir leur pension
progresser sur ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt qui exercent souvent des
emplois pénibles précaires ceux qui ont
des carrières hachées et donc
principalement les femmes
ce sont toutes ces personnes qui ont été
peu reconnues lors de la crise sanitaire
et qui subissent maintenant l'inflation
de plein fouet cette réforme augmentera
la précarité de nos compatriotes qui
après 55 ans sont souvent hélas déjà
poussés vers la sortie le chômage ou le
RSA conscient des inégalités que vous
aggravez vous avez tenté d'atténuer
l'injustice de votre projet on
introduisant des mesures caches misères
mal calibrées quitte à aboutir à des
usines à gaz la promesse de pension
minimum à 1200 euros pour tous n'est
qu'une illusion voire un mensonge révélé
par l'obstination de plusieurs de nos
collègues à demander la vérité
après nous avoir dit qu'il n'avait aucun
compte à nous rendre le ministre a
reconnu que la mesure ne toucherait pas
200 000 bénéficiaires mais entre 10000
et 20 000 personnes chaque année
autre tour de passe-passe celle de faire
croire que nos concitoyens qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 21 ans de
cotiserait jamais plus de 43 ans tout
ceci est faux les conditions pour
bénéficier du dispositif carrière longue
sont bien plus complexes la réalité
c'est que dans deux tiers des cas ces
personnes devront cotiser plus de 43 à
nuités
j'en viens
j'en viens à présent à votre deuxième
argument le redressement des comptes de
la branche retraite avant tout je
rappellerai les insuffisantes de l'étude
d'impact qui ne permet pas de mesurer
les incidences exactes de cette réforme
l’insécurité budgétaire de ce texte doit
être souligné ainsi les 17,7 milliards
d'économies ne tiennent pas compte des
effets du à la croissance des dépenses
sur l'assurance maladie le RSA les
allocations chômage à l'invalidité que
les spécialistes estiment entre le tiers
et le quart des économies à réaliser et
hallucides l'accord trouvé en CMP les
dépenses supplémentaires s'élèvent à un
peu plus de 7 milliards tout cela
biboutabot il est permis de penser que
votre réforme ne pourrait finalement
aboutir qu'à un milliard d'économies par
an d'ici 2030 une France au bord du
précipice pour un milliard la priorité
serait plutôt de s'attaquer monsieur le
ministre du Budget au déficit de 155
milliards du budget de l'État
ainsi non seulement vous n'arrivez pas à
atténuer l'injustice de cette réforme
mais par ailleurs vous n'assurez pas non
plus l'équilibre du système de retraite
c'est bien qu'au final on s'interroge
tout ça pour ça le président de la
République invente un dernier argument
il faudrait imposer la rigueur
budgétaire pour ne pas perdre la
crédibilité de la France sur les marchés
financiers mais c'est précisément le
recours au 49-3 et la crise politique et
sociale qu'il provoque qui peut affoler
les marchés et faire exploser le coup de
notre dette madame la Première ministre
nous avons proposé une porte de sortie
retirez votre projet et nous remettre au
travail aujourd'hui je vais vous dire
notre inquiétude nous voyons un pays qui
se déchire des institutions bloquées une
démocratie aujourd'hui
nous avons besoin de retrouver le chemin
de l'écoute du dialogue du merci respect
de nos
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie de vouloir quitter la
tribune mon cher collègue
mon chers collègues dans cette assemblée
nous avons des règles des temps de
parole qui sont limitées je vous demande
de quitter la tribune
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame l'heure la
Valette pour le rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci beaucoup
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues pourquoi
sommes-nous là aujourd'hui le 20 mars
2023 prêt à censurer votre gouvernement
pour empêcher une réforme des retraites
dont personne ne veut pourquoi la
réponse est simple mais elle mérite
d'être appelée parce que l'ego
gouvernemental n'a d'égal que la
contestation qu'il provoque contre lui
cette ego il a notamment conduit la
première ministre à utiliser 11 fois le
49-3 depuis juin dernier sans que la
brutalité ne s'efface au profit de la
lassitude madame la première minute vous
nous avez dit jeudi dernier en annonçant
votre onzième 49,3 sur cette réforme des
retraites je vous cite ce compromis
n'est pas le projet du gouvernement
c'est le texte du Parlement mais quel
culots quel culot madame la Première
ministre
l'utilisation
l'utilisation que vous faites de la
Constitution depuis le début de cette
législature prouve que vous ne
chercherez jamais à trouver le moindre
compromis ni avec les parlementaires que
nous sommes ni avec les représentations
syndicales et encore moins avec les
Français cela a commencé par
l'utilisation fortement contestable du
47-1 qui a montré une fois de plus votre
difficulté à convaincre préférant ainsi
sécuriser un texte que vous saviez
rejeté par une très large majorité des
Français puis l'utilisation de l'article
44 3 lors des débats au Sénat permettant
un vote unique sur l'ensemble du texte
et sur plusieurs amendements que vous
avez déniés retenir mais les brillants
constitutionnalistes que vous êtes ont
oublié un article celui qui donne la
parole au seul souverain le peuple je
pense bien sûr à l'article 11
le référendum aurait pu permettre
d'éviter de tomber dans cette nouvelle
crise politique qui illustre qu'aucune
leçon depuis les gilets jaunes n'a été
retenu par l'oligarchie en démocratie
vous savez ça n'est pas honteux de
reculer face à la volonté du peuple en
déclenchant ses 49-3 c'est précisément
elle que vous tentez de forcer mais
madame la Première ministre il est trop
tard quel que soit l'issue de ce vote ce
jour vous aurez échoué échoué à
convaincre la représentation nationale
mais surtout échoué et c'est finalement
ça qui compte échouer à convaincre les
Français madame la Première ministre si
votre brutalité n'étonne plus personne
elle s'est accompagnée cette fois-ci
d'une propension aux mensonges et au
contournement marqué et remarqué
jusqu'au bout et dans un cynisme absolu
vous avez tenté de dissimuler les
manquements de votre projet cynisme
quand le nombre réel de bénéficiaires de
la promesse d'une retraite minimale à
1200 euros et passer de 2 millions à 10
000 cynisme lorsque Monsieur
ose dire à la représentation nationale
qui n'a aucun compte à lui rendre
foulant ainsi au pied notre Constitution
cynisme encore quand aucun ministre
n'aigné réponds sur votre dispositif
carrière longue qui tire à pile ou face
la durée de cotisation de ceux qui ont
commencé tôt 43 ans 44 ans on ne
comprend pas mais bien loin du juste
prix c'est à la roue de l'infortune que
vous jouez mais rien de moins étonnant
gardez le silence et rester ambigu était
le seul moyen de tenter de vendre votre
réforme dont tout jusqu'à la
justification même de son existence et
bancale souvenez-vous elle devait être
inévitable
imposée par un prétendu déficit qui
menacerait notre système de retraite par
répartition et le conduirait à la
faillite cet argument d'autorité aurait
pu vous rendre la tâche bien facile mais
tous les économistes du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites lui-même et
parfois quelques membres dévoués du
gouvernement merci Monsieur Riester
l'ont désavoué
nous refusons nous refusons que la vie
des Français soit la variable
d'ajustement de votre politique
désastreuse et nous ne sommes pas dupe
sur les raisons qui vous poussent à
chercher des économies sur leur dos
malgré les redomontades de Monsieur le
Maire le bilan est bien là plus de 600
milliards d'euros de dettes à l'issue du
premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
déficit commercial de 174 milliards 2
millions d'emplois industriels perdus en
30 ans une natalité au plus bas depuis
la Seconde Guerre mondiale une fraude
fiscale et sociale de 80 milliards
dois-je continuer alors madame la
Première ministre solution forte et
courageuse vous avez préféré le Maras
mais l'enlisement dans la précarisation
et la diminution des droits de nos
compatriotes
vous portez une réforme d'injustice
sociale sans commune mesure un pas en
arrière sur toutes les aspirations
protectrices que notre pays a toujours
eu l'honneur de mettre en place alors
que nos compatriotes le comprennent bien
le report de l'âge de départ ne les fera
pas seulement travailler deux ans de
plus y compris ce qui sont usés il
aboutira à la régression suprême la
baisse des pensions par l'effondrement
des surcottes et par l'augmentation des
décotes voilà madame la Premier ministre
la réalité de votre réforme à l'inverse
notre projet pour les retraites c'est
clair et juste plus on a commencé tôt
plus on travaille dur et donc plus on
part tôt avec Marine Le Pen un jeune
ayant commencé avant 20 ans ne cotisera
pas plus de 40 à nuitée et pour ainsi le
souhaite bénéficier d'une retraite bien
méritée à partir de 60 ans et pour ceux
ayant commencé à partir après 20 ans ce
sera progressif sans jamais dépasser 42
à nuités et 62 annuités et pas une année
de plus
notre projet s'accompagne de mesure de
bon sens figuez
je parle bien sûr ici de productivité et
de natalité car oui mes chers collègues
oui ce ne sont pas des gros mots
ce ne sont pas des gros mots mais bien
les fondations d'un système de retraite
par répartition juste et efficace pour
une société du plein emploi qualitatif
et contre une société du plein emploi
ubérisé réindustrialisant le pays
produisons les richesses en France
donnant la priorité aux entreprises
françaises dans les marchés publics
supprimons la CFE qui pénalise les
entreprises locales baissons les impôts
de production qui nuisent à la
relocalisation pour une société qui
mesure la nécessité vitale d'une
natalité forte soutenant financièrement
les Français qui souhaitent agrandir
leur famille facilitons l'accès à la
propriété des jeunes couples et
institons une part fiscale pleine dès le
deuxième enfant notre mission votre
mission devrait être entièrement tournée
vers la défense des intérêts de la
France et des Français et cette mission
ne peut s'envisager sans une approbation
du peuple je le répète unique souverain
de notre pays la tâche qui est celle du
législateur n'est pas la plus aisée mais
elle est la plus essentielle rédiger les
lois par lesquelles se manifestent la
volonté souveraine en refusant de
retirer votre réforme et en refusant de
passer par la voie référendaire vous
entacher dans votre honneur que nos
missions de parlementaires je vous en
conjure madame la Première ministre
prenez un peu de hauteur Émile Durkheim
expliciter la pensée de Rousseau ainsi
lorsque le souverain est gifers sur les
individus et sur lui qu'il légifère et
c'est en deux que réside cette puissance
législative qui s'exerce par lui la loi
n'est pas et ne doit pas être issue de
la force de quelques-uns sur une masse
d'individus il apparaît donc nécessaire
qu’emmanuel Macron et que son
gouvernement et que vous madame borne
retrouviez la modestie nécessaire à la
bonne application de notre Constitution
qui veut que la souveraineté nationale
appartiennent au peuple
le 21 mai 1850 lors de son discours en
faveur du suffrage universel et contre
un projet de loi visant à l'empêcher
victor Hugo a cette tribune disait ces
mots
cette loi est invalide cette loi est
nulle cette loi est morte avant même
d'être née et savez-vous s'il vous plaît
dans le pays de la franchise c'est
qu'elle est déloyale dans le premier
pays de l'honnêteté c'est qu'elle n'est
pas juste c'est qu'elle n'est pas vrai
c'est qu'elle cherche en vain à créer
une fausse justice et une fausse vérité
sociale de ces mots madame la Premier
ministre je n'en effacerai pas un seul
au sujet de votre funeste réforme alors
nous voilà maintenant
nous voilà maintenant à quelques minutes
dans votre décision et je m'adresse à
vous chers collègues de tout bord votre
intégrité de parlementaire n'est-elle
pas heurtée par les marchandages en
provenance de l'Élysée comment
tolérez-vous la menace d'une dissolution
dès lors que le Président de la
République cherche à vous convaincre
acceptez-vous de participer ainsi au
delitement de notre démocratie sauf ceux
de mauvaise foi nous savons tous ici
qu'une motion de censure n'est pas un
programme commun pas plus qu'une volonté
de gouverner ensemble mais elle est
avant tout l'un des derniers moyens
constitutionnel de rejeter cette réforme
inutile et injuste dont l'immense
majorité des Français ne veut pas en
unissant nos voix nous exprimerions
uniquement la volonté du peuple de
France sur ce texte
chers collègues
cette motion de censure est l'occasion
de sortir de certaines postures
idéologiques qui font tant de mal au
vrais débat d'idées quand l'intérêt
supérieur de la France et des Français
l'exigent nous députés du rassemblement
national nous voterons toutes l'émotion
de censure car nous ne craindrons jamais
les urnes et sommes prêts à y retourner
les Français peuvent compter sur
l'ensemble des députés de notre groupe
pour exercer avec détermination sérénité
sérieux le mandat qui leur a été confié
et c'est vers eux que je me tourne mes
chers collègues je suis fier de ces géo
auprès de femmes et d'hommes dont la
seule force de conviction et l'amour de
notre pays les ont conduits ici sans
jamais dévier sans jamais se promettre
fier de siéger auprès de femmes et
d'hommes qui depuis le début ont fait
honneur à leur mandat et mesure
quotidiennement l'ampleur des
responsabilités qui leur a été confiée
fier de ces jets auprès des femmes et
d'hommes dont les choix et les actions
ne dépendent d'une seule chose le souci
de leur peuple et le bien commun votre
exemplarité mes chers collègues ne vous
demande aucun effort éprouve que rien
strictement rien ne pourra vous
détourner de ce feu ardent nourri de
l'amour d'un pays et de son peuple fier
enfin et surtout de siéger dans ce
groupe porté par une présidente Marine
Le Pen qui n'a jamais eu d'autres
boussole que l'intérêt des siens que
l'intérêt des nôtres et qui a mené
l'opposition dans votre réforme délétère
avec vigueur responsabilité et dignité
alors
chiche monsieur Macron alors chiche
allons à la dissolution et demain nous
reviendrons plus nombreux encore à
l'Assemblée nationale pour donner un
groupe plus puissant le rassemblement
national à 15 minutes
allez-y ma chère collègue alors Monsieur
Macron allons à la dissolution et demain
nous reviendrons plus en nombreux encore
pour donner un groupe plus puissant
voire majoritaire à Marine Le Pen car
plus que jamais je suis convaincu que
nous sommes la véritable alternance
convaincue qu'après vous ce sera nous et
si la tâche est rendue particulièrement
ardu par 6 ans de politique macronistes
nous sommes prêts prêts à rendre à la
France à fierté celle d'avoir été une
grande nation sociale et éclairante dans
le monde prêt à donner à ce peuple fier
et fort le courage de bâtir une France
plus grande une France apaisée à
l'unisson si nous avons désormais
beaucoup à réparer les fondations de la
maison France son peuple demeure intacte
et contrairement à ce qu'il subisse avec
vous les Français savent que nous ne
ferons jamais rien sans jeu et jamais
rien contre eux bien loin des
régressions sociales économiques
culturelles et diplomatiques nous rêvons
d’une grandeur retrouvée de prospérité
et de justice nous rêvons que notre
grand peuple fraternel et épris de
liberté ne soient plus jamais maltraitée
chez lui parce que nous sommes
nous-mêmes libres de tout intérêt
financier ou étrangers nous savons que
la fatalité n'existe pas plutôt que la
bassesse de cette réforme nous proposons
aux Français de choisir la hauteur d'une
vision globale et courageuse pour le
pays vivre dans une France où chacun
peut trouver le bonheur partout et la
justice tout le temps voilà ce que nous
voulons vivre dans une France ou aucune
famille ne doit se priver des choses
essentielles vivre dans une France où
tous les étudiants mangent à leur faim
vivent dans une France où les services
publics sont performants vivent dans une
France où les infirmières les policiers
les agriculteurs et les conducteurs de
bus seraient rémunérés dignement vivre
dans une France où tous les quartiers
seraient sûrs vivent dans une France où
l'école laisse sa chance à tous
vivre dans une France qui n'a pas peur
de créer d'innover et qui s'en donne les
moyens enfin vivre dans une France qui
mesure ce qu'elle vaut qui sait d'où
elle vient et qui n'a pas peur de
s'affirmer alors nous le disons haut et
fort à tous ceux qui nous font part de
leurs sentiments d'un acharnement
inhumain de la part d'un gouvernement à
la dérive tenait bon tenez bon 2027
n'est plus si loin
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Aurore Bergé
présidente du groupe Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
merci merci madame la Présidente
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
j'ai entendu les deux motions de censure
et leurs deux présentations j'ai pas pu
m'empêcher de venir à cette tribune sans
ce qui devrait être tous nous réunir à
savoir notre Constitution et oui et oui
je ne crois pas que cela prête à rire
notre Constitution parce qu'elle est en
fait le bien commun qui doit réunir les
parlementaires parce que nos
institutions sont solides et
heureusement elles le sont et les deux
motions de censure en sont la
démonstration
vous parlez aujourd'hui d'une motion de
censure dite transpart tisane
transpartizane à la fois dans certaines
de ces signatures mais la question
transpartisane elle se pose surtout au
moment du vote savoir avec qui on est
prêt ou non à lier son vote savoir avec
qui on est prêt ou non à voter de part
et d'autre de cette émission là
parce que mes chers collègues
c'est trop facile
l'après-midi s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît un peu de silence
alors parce que mes chers collègues oui
contrairement à ce que vous avez dit
Madame La Valette oui une motion de
censure des facto devient un programme
commun parce qu'une motion de censure
c'est la capacité à trouver une
alternative crédible à dégager une autre
majorité et donc en fonction de celles
ou ceux qui voteront ensemble cette
motion de censure qui s'applaudiront
ensemble pour le vote de cette motion de
censure alors vous direz aux Français
quelle est prétendument la majorité
alternative alors vous direz aux
Français quel est prétendument le
gouvernement alternatif avec Charles de
Courson en premier ministre avec Marine
Le Pen à Bercy avec Mathilde panot un
ministre de l'Intérieur et avec un
empanité Aurélien Pradier ministre des
Relations avec le Parlement c'est ça le
projet alternatif que vous soumettez
aujourd'hui aux Français
quand on parle de grandes coalition on
est ensemble pour un projet commun on
est ensemble pour continuer à
transformer son pays on est ensemble
pour permettre de faire que ce pays
avance c'est l'inverse que vous nous
proposez aujourd'hui avec une motion de
censure qui vise à mettre à l'arrêt
notre pays qui vise à créer du blocage
non seulement dans nos institutions mais
évidemment du blocage dans la rue
alors oui mes chers collègues
retraçons ensemble ces dernières
semaines celle que nous avons vécu
parfois subis dans cette hémicycle
[Musique]
d'abord je dois le dire et je le dis
s'il vous plaît au nom de mon groupe de
manière claire il y a ceux qui ont été
solides et cette solidité madame la
Première ministre c'est d'abord la vôtre
celle qui avait résisté avec courage et
avec dignité malgré les cris de cette
hémicycle malgré l'impossibilité qui
vous était faite de parler vous vous
êtes exprimé de manière claire et vous
avez fait honneur à la vie politique et
à la vie démocratique de notre pays
il y a la solidité de ceux qui ont
défendu et qui ont porté ce projet
essentiel pour nos compatriotes d'abord
le ministre du Travail que vous n'avez
eu de cesse d'invectiver d'insulter de
piétiner au sens figuré mais en vérité
finalement vous aviez envie de le faire
au sens propre oui Olivier du stop avec
Gabriel Attal on portait avec courage le
projet qui est aujourd'hui soumis à vos
votes
alors retraçons oui retraçons ces
dernières semaines d'abord du côté
gauche de cette hémicycle vous nous
dites qu'il y a quatre groupes dans
cette hémicycle mais en vérité comment
aujourd'hui vous différencier vous avez
assumé accepté un accord électoral un
accord électoral qui a fait disparaître
trois parties qui étaient des parties de
gouvernement qui a fait disparaître des
parties qui avaient des valeurs communes
pire que ça quand un homme s'est levé
quand André Chassaigne s'est levé pour
dénoncer des agissements indignes pour
dire la honte qui était la sienne pas un
d'entre vous ne s'est levé pour
l'applaudir nous étions seuls avec les
républicains à nous lever pour condamner
ce geste et pour applaudir votre
président de groupe j'imagine qu'il doit
y avoir des petites notes et des
tableaux Excel pour savoir quelles sont
les députés de la nupesse qui ne se
comporteraient pas bien avec la France
insoumise parce que oui votre angoisse
ult ime c'est qu'une dissolution existe
et qu'un candidat de la France insoumise
soit présenté face à vous demain en cas
de dissolution alors non non ne fâchons
pas trop Jean-Luc Mélenchon continuant à
l'applaudir quand il est à la tribune de
cette hémistique continuons à considérer
qu'il est député continuant à considérer
qu'il est président de parti puisque de
toute façon c'est à Lui évidemment que
vous répondez en dernier ressort
ensuite
il y a cette motion de censure présentée
en grande partie par le groupe liotte
avec une diversité qui n'a de vous aura
pas échappé chers collègues dans la
composition de votre groupe mais je
parle à ceux qui dans votre groupe on
défendu la réforme des retraites qui ont
défendu la candidature de François
Fillon qui disait allons-y allons à la
retraite à 65 ans et je pense notamment
à Charles de Courson puisque lui-même
avait assumé avec clarté cette campagne
et puis il y a le groupe les
républicains et en vérité la vérité nous
oblige à dire que oui oui nous avions un
compromis que nous avions bâti ensemble
oui parce que ça n'est pas un gros mot
dans la vie politique et démocratique
que d'établir du consensus et que
d'établir des compromis parce que c'est
la force même de notre assemblée que de
tout faire pour que des compromis
existent et ce compromis il a été
souhaité ardemment et voté il a été voté
au Sénat au Sénat la droite à la
majorité absolue et la droite a voté au
Sénat en commission mixte paritaire oui
cela a été voté par le président du
groupe Olivier Marleix et à ceux qui
disent de part et d'autre de cette
hémicycle que la CMP serait une vision
dégradée de la démocratie qu'elles honte
quelle honte la commission mixte
paritaire c'est la capacité à faire
travailler nos deux chambres ensemble où
est la difficulté enfin à dire
clairement aux Français que Senna et
assemblés peuvent travailler ensemble
pour faire émerger des compromis qui ici
qui a déjà chez Géant TMP ne peut oser
franchement regardez les Français dans
les yeux et leur dire que la CMP c'est
de la manigance ou c'est de la manœuvre
au contraire la CMP c'est de la clarté
et c'est la capacité à dégager des
compromis mais au sein de votre groupe
il y a eu malheureusement des
trajectoires personnelles il y a eu des
calculs individuels qui ne sont en rien
mais alors en rien motivé par l'intérêt
général en rien motivé par l'intérêt des
Français parce que vous le savez les
demandes que vous avez eu ces demandes
qui pouvaient être légitimes notamment
sur les carrières longues elles sont
satisfaite dans ce texte mais il fallait
à nouveau trouver un prétexte prétexte
après prétexte pour ne pas voter alors
oui moi je retiens ceux qui au sein de
votre partie ce qui au sein des
républicains ont
en commission mix paritaire et disent
aujourd'hui dans les médias disent
aujourd'hui sur le terrain qu'ils
assument une réforme nécessaire pour
notre pays et oui qu'ils ont honte en
effet de voir certains de leurs familles
politiques assumer de voter une motion
non seulement transpartisable mais avec
l'extrême droite j'ai connu en partie
politique ou en effet il y avait des
digues qui étaient clairs avec l'extrême
droite je sais que c'est vous sont très
minoritaires et j'espère qu'elle le
resteront car oui nous avons besoin de
partie républicains de parties claires
avec leurs valeurs et puis enfin
enfin il y a l'extrême droite je sais
que vous n'aimez pas ce terme mais c'est
quand même comme ça qu'on continue à
vous caractériser parce que c'est ce que
vous êtes au fond de vous c'est ce que
sont vos valeurs et finalement
finalement que dire sur le rassemblement
national en fait pousser un peu le mime
Marceau sa gesticule mais ça parle pas
parce qu'on vous demande de vous taire
parce que surtout il faudrait pas
prendre le risque qu'un seul député du
rassemblement national s'exprime parce
que quand vous vous exprimez ça finit en
dérapage et on se souvient qui vous êtes
et l'assemblé le condamne avec un député
qui a été interdit de notre hémicycle
pendant 15 jours pour un dérapages
graves à l'encontre d'un de nos
collègues oui c'est ce qui s'est passé
pendant toute cette séquence et puis
un peu de silence on écoute madame la
Présidente
s'il vous plaît mais si vous voulez
parler vous savez chers collègues que
l'avez-vous fait pendant les 15 jours de
débat que n'avez-vous pris ce micro
pendant les 15 jours de débat que
n'avez-vous déposé des amendements
n’êtes-vous allé en médias pour assumer
de porter une contradiction la vérité
elle est claire il y a un chef une chef
et seul elle a droit à la parole les
autres doivent d'abord se taire et
appuyer sur le bouton ou lever la main
quand on leur demande c'est ça la triste
vérité quelle rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
et puis
et puis enfin il y a face à moi la
majorité les trois groupes de la
majorité
Unis soudée responsable qui ont assumé
et qui assument jusqu'au bout leur
valeur leur convictions et qui le font
sur le terrain tous les jours oui nous
le savons madame la Présidente
mais ce courage la majorité là et je
veux rendre hommage en particulier à
notre président de commission en fait il
a katabi et à Stéphanie notre rapporteur
général
[Applaudissements]
et oui oui j'assume de défendre nous
assumons de défendre ce texte dans
l'émotion de censure encore nous avons
entendu les fausses vérités sur l'état
de nos comptes publics quels dommage
sert de Courson quand justement on a
fait toute sa carrière et sa vie
politique cette mandats parlementaire
pour parler de la restauration de nos
comptes publics parce que oui sans cette
réforme à la fin en disant nous aurons
accumulé 150 milliards de déficits la
vérité elle est là et vous ne pouvez pas
la contester la vérité c'est que oui la
justice est d'abord de faire en sorte
que cette réforme soit adoptée parce que
ceux qui vont trinquer ceux qui
trinqueraient en premier ce sont les
plus fragiles de notre pays qui eux
n'ont que la solidarité
intergénérationnelle pour faire en sorte
d'espérer un jour avoir le droit à une
retraite et oui cette réforme en effet
elle demande du courage parce que
demander des efforts aux Français c'est
toujours plus difficile que de dire que
demain on rase gratis avec de l'argent
qu'on n'a pas et avec des efforts qu'on
ne demande pas et ce sont ces efforts
qui ont fait en sorte que nous sommes
potentiellement aux portes du plein
emploi dans notre pays parce que nous
avons 7,2 % de taux de chômage alors
qu'en 2017 nous étions après de 10% de
taux de chômage ça c'est concret ça
c'est l'avenir de nos France des
Français l'avenir de nos concitoyens et
la manière avec laquelle ils peuvent le
regarder plus sereinement
et l'avenir oui c'est ce qui doit nous
appartenir à partir de ce soir car
quelle que soit le résultat souverain de
notre assemblée qui votera qui votera
pour dire oui ou non à la réforme qui
votera pour dire oui ou non à la censure
alors oui il y aura un après et cet
après il est de notre responsabilité
pendant les débats au sein de
l'assemblée combien de fois avons-nous
été interpellé par des Français qui nous
écrivaient ou qui nous interpellait
directement en nous disant j'ai honte de
regarder ces débats j'ai honte de ce que
l'assemblée est devenu j'ai honte de ce
bruit et de ce vacarme permanent j'ai
honte du tapis rouge que vous dressez à
l'extrême droite parce que si l'extrême
droite peut conclure son discours en
disant en 2027 c'est bientôt c'est parce
que vous êtes là et parce que vous
n'êtes pas un rempart vous êtes en
marche pied
[Applaudissements]
alors oui oui nous devons réussir
collectivement allez au-delà du
ressentiment que peut provoquer cette
réforme allez au-delà de l'amertume
qu'elle peut provoquer à partir du
moment oui nous demandons des efforts
oui nous devons ouvrir des chantiers qui
sont dans l'intérêt des Français et qui
sont vitaux pour l'avenir de notre pays
je pense évidemment à la question du
travail parce que la question des
retraites elle pose fondamentalement
d'abord la question du travail de
rapport au travail du sens du travail de
la rémunération du travail dans notre
société c'est toute la question du
partage de la valeur et du partage des
profits que nous voulons voir être mis
en oeuvre dans les prochaines semaines
c'est la question de la de l'autonomie
aussi et de nos aînés combien de
familles sont touchées par la dépendance
par la perte d'autonomie nous avons créé
la cinquième branche nous toute la
majorité avant déposé une proposition de
loi sur l'autonomie et le Bien Vieillir
ça c'est la vie quotidienne
dont il est question alors oui ou non
serons-nous capables à l'issue des votes
de ce soir de trouver dans cette
hémicycle dans cette hémicycle que les
Français ont choisi à la fois dans la
majorité et avec les personnes de bonne
volonté de droite comme de gauche seront
nous capables de voter des textes qui
sont structurants seront nous capables
demain de voter un texte inédit de
soutien à nos forces armées pour lutter
contre le terrorisme seront nous demain
de voter un texte majeur sur l'accès aux
soins pour les plus précaires en
particulier la défense de notre hôpital
public seront nous capables de voter
notre texte sur l'autonomie seront nous
capables de continuer à prendre le
tournant de la planification écologique
seront nous capables de décarboner notre
industrie et de porter une industrie
verte seront nous capables ensemble de
refonder notre pacte républicain et
notre école serons-nous capables
d'assumer un discours clair sur
l'immigration qui dit que oui on doit
régulariser ce qui s'intègre par le
travail mais que oui on doit évidemment
expulser ce qui en freine nos valeurs
pas là ou l'autre là et l'autre alors
en conclusion face aux extrêmes face aux
alliances de circonstances qu'on a vu
fleurir ces derniers jours face aux
opportunistes de tout bord face au
cynisme qui peut trop souvent exister
ici oui la réponse encore et toujours
elle est dans le dépassement et elle est
dans le rassemblement les Français nous
ont talus les Français nous ont choisi
les Français sont prêts au dépassement
et au rassemblement la majorité y est
prête que celles et ceux qui sont de
bonnes volonté s'engagent avec nous je
vous remercie je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
la Présidente panneau pour le groupe la
France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
présidente première ministre collègues
le peuple vous regarde
il vous regarde comme on regarde
quelqu'un qui a trahi dans un mélange de
colère et de dégoût
la colère et le dégoût sont familiers
les Français l'ont éprouvé au lendemain
d'un dimanche de 2005 depuis ils ont
déserté les urnes ils sont retournés
parfois ils étaient déçus en 2017
résigné en mars 2022 ils vous ont
sanctionné en juin dernier et vous les
avez à nouveau trahis
en faisant comme si Emmanuel Macron
avait été élu sur son programme trahi en
gouvernant depuis 9 mois comme si vous
étiez majoritaire trahi avec un
misérable 49.3 pour faire passer une
réforme dont personne ne veut des
traîtres donc mais d'un genre nouveau de
ceux qui déçoivent les espoirs que l'on
n'a jamais placé en eux car en avril
dernier personne ne comptait réellement
sur Emmanuel Macron pour relever le pays
ont prêté une oreille distraite à celui
qui parlait alors souvenez-vous d'une
nouvelle méthode pour gouverner des
milliers de mensonges plus tard vous
portez le coup de grâce vous envisagez
pas l'hypothèse du 49-3 juste avant d'y
recourir votre parole n'a plus aucune
valeur des
ossements de sourcils des rires narquois
des injures sont au mieux ce que vous
récoltez dans le pays jamais un
président n'a voulu gouverner avec
autant d'aplombs par la colère et le
dégoût à présent deux Français sur trois
veulent que cette motion de censure
aboutisse pour faire chuter le
gouvernement et votre réforme oui je dis
était le premier jour de la fin du
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron vous
n'avez aucune légitimité à faire cette
réforme et vous le savez votre défaite
est d'autant plus grande que vous aviez
mobilisé tout un arsenal pour l'imposer
de force 50 jours pour discuter d'un
texte un temps de parole limitée des
petits accords de couloir des ministres
qui défilent pour parler d'une réforme
juste et équilibrée de gauche et qui ne
fera pas de perdant d'autres qui
accusent les grévistes de provoquer une
catastrophe éc ologique agricole et
sanitaire un vote bloqué au Sénat un
bras d'honneur à l'Assemblée pour finir
par un 49-3 sous forme d'aveugle de
faiblesse quelle misère morale et
politique ni légitimité populaire ni
légitime parlementaire vous avez
précipité le pays dans une crise de
régime
l'artisan de ce chaos est porté disparu
Emmanuel Macron se cache depuis des
semaines derrière ses fusibles il
communique uniquement par correspondance
un jour pour dire que cette réforme est
nécessaire l'autre pour souhaiter que le
texte je cite puisse aller au bout de
son cheminement démocratique quand il
n'a emprunté qu'un sentier autoritaire
après son passage en force il fait de la
France dès le lendemain matin la risée
du monde le journal conservateur d'air
tagash Figel titre Macron n'est pas un
réformateur mais un démolisseur ce 49-3
est une catastrophe politique pour le
journal libéral dit économiste on voit
mal du positif émergé de cette pagaille
le journal italien la Stompa évêque un
geste trop irréfléchi qui peut déborder
l'Élysée un journal danois évoque une
bombe nucléaire déclenchée dans un cas
au total pour El Pais ce 49-3 va
empoisonner la vie politique le New York
Times évoque une méthode qui traduit une
forme de mépris oui Emmanuel Macron fait
honte à la France
les Français avaient pourtant joué le
jeu avec des syndicats Unis il
manifestaient pacifiquement depuis des
semaines faisaient grève perdez des
jours de salaire au moment même où les
prix explosent avec ce 49-3 Emmanuel
Macron souffle à l'oreille du pays un
raisonnement dangereux en démocratie
pour être entendu la démocratie ne
suffit plus que reste-t-il alors le
forcené de l'Élysée et des goupilles une
grenaille et bouge toutes les issues il
ne laisse au peuple aucune porte de
sortie il porte l'entière responsabilité
d'une explosion de colère en démocratie
pourtant le peuple est le seul souverain
si Emmanuel Macron voulait réparer le
pays il pourrait annoncer un référendum
ou une dissolution mais il a fait du
peuple son ennemi
un mort un conseiller du président parle
d'un mort le roi demande un sacrifice
contre le retrait de la réforme la
situation est grave inédite dans notre
histoire politique récente jamais un
président et féministe n'avait autant et
délibérément menacé la paix civile du
pays qu'il gouverne madame la Première
ministre il faut donc vous s’insérer
pour l'intérêt de tous
on lit ici et là qu'Emmanuel Macron se
rêve en Jésus-Christ il ressemble
davantage à Caligula cette empereur
devenue ivre de son pouvoir
Camus fait dire Alain de ses personnages
sans doute ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'un homme dispose d'un pouvoir sans
limite mais c'est la première fois qu'il
s'en sert sans limite jusqu'à ni et
l'homme et le monde comme Caligula le
président est saisi de deux mesures il
n'écoute plus personne il a refusé de
recevoir l'Inter syndicale l'ignorer des
manifestations historiques depuis 50 ans
commander un passage en force et se
barre barricades désormais dans son
palais comme lui il désire l'impossible
ni l'adhésion à son projet ni l'adhésion
à sa réforme ne sont de ce monde mais il
fera comme si à croire qu'Emmanuel
Macron se trompe de peuple il croit
possible de gouverner la France
indépendamment des Français
indépendamment de la fureur qu'il fait
naître en eux comme lui il confond la
postérité et le ridicule comme s'il se
met la colère et le dégoût dans le pays
avec quelque chose d'original comme lui
il confond la force et la lâcheté comme
si pénaliser les femmes les plus
précaires et épargner les riches avec
quelque chose de courageux avec le même
signe que le Caligula de Camus il dit
gouverner ses volets tout le monde sait
ça mais il y a la manière moi je
volerais franchement oui Emmanuel Macron
volera franchement des ans de vie à tous
les Français la colère et le dégoût
comme seul programme politique quelle
temps perdu il y avait pourtant tant à
faire la sécheresse ravage le pays
80% des nappes phréatiques sont à des
niveaux catastrophiques une étude
récente nous dit que la demande en eau
douce excédera de 40% les ressources
disponibles dans les 7 années à venir
les grandes entreprises profitent de
l'inflation pour gonfler leur prix et
dégager plus de marge pendant ce temps
les Français en sont réduits à voler
dans les supermarchés
on sait que les 12 milliards que vous
cherchez pour les retraites se trouvent
dans la poche des plus riches qui ne
fait pas d'impôts comme le révèle
l'Institut des politiques publiques
quel temps perdu à répandre la colère et
le dégoût
heureusement il y a de quoi se résiduir
pas ici non jamais là-bas au dehors
depuis des semaines des millions de
personnes défilent dans les rues pas
pour le plaisir car elles y perdent des
plumes mais pour leur dignité
ils ont ceci de différents de vous
qu'ils prennent leur existence et celles
des autres au sérieux même si vous lui
accordez bien peu de valeur ils tiennent
à la vie à leur vie ils tiennent à leur
vie car ils n'en n'ont pas d'autres ils
tiennent à leur vie et non personne en
haut pour la défendre au fond vous
misiez sur un océan de dégoût pour faire
passer votre réforme mais même cela vous
n'y êtes pas parvenu le 49.3 a fait
l'effet d'un détonateur
jeudi dernier des centaines de milliers
de gens dans tout le pays ce sont réunis
spontanément sidérés par votre brutalité
ils savent où réside la violence la
vraie pas dans des autocollants
placardés sur une permanence mais dans
le fait d'imposer deux enfermes de
briser d'user d'épuiser encore davantage
les corps et les nerfs comme à chaque
fois vous vous servez de la police pour
répandre le dégoût en quelques jours on
a vu poindre le spectre des gilets
jaunes dans le maintien du désordre
jeudi soir 97% des personnes
interpellées ont été relâchés 100
poursuites
1400 garde à vue prolongées inutilement
des jeunes manifestants humiliés à
Genouillé le dos au mur les mains sur la
tête des charges violentes et
injustifiées des nasses et fouilles
arbitraires vous tentez désespérément de
relancer la machine à découragement vous
n'y parviendrez pas vous n'y parviendrez
pas car la période a révélé aux yeux de
tous une réalité insoutenable vous ne
servez à rien oui vous ne servez à rien
si ce n'est nuire
quand les éboueurs font grève du jour le
paysage et les odeurs s'en trouvent
changer si votre gouvernement tombait ce
soir les Français seraient simplement
soulagés
madame la Première ministre vous ne
pouvez rien face à ceux qui font tout
peu importe l'issue de cette motion de
censure vous avez déjà perdu pour
beaucoup votre gouvernement est déjà
mort au moment où vous passiez en force
par arrogance votre pouvoir s'est
effondré les noms de bornes du soft et
autres n'inspire aux Français ko Le cœur
l'Inter syndical donne rendez-vous ce
jeudi pour la motion de censure
populaire nous parlerons de votre
réforme au passé car ce n'est qu'une
question de jours avant que vous ne
reculiez enfants malgré vos efforts
personne ne se laissera envahir par le
dégoût chacune de vos paroles est un
antidote à l'impuissance et à la
résignation le désir de battre Emmanuel
Macron et sa réforme est devenue
contagieuse
même l'empereur Caligula a été vaincu
c'était après cette regardée dans le
miroir merci de ton Emmanuel Macron
conte le son reflet il y verra bientôt
sa chute
merci beaucoup
la parole est au président Marleix pour
le groupe les républicains
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mes chers collègues oui nous
assumons la nécessité d'une réforme pour
sauvegarder notre système de retraite et
défendre le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités le respect du travail c'est
aussi le droit à une retraite décente
après une vie de travail oui nous
assumons d'avoir tempéré cette réforme
63 ans à la fin du quinquennat plutôt
que 65 ans oui nous assumons dans
redistribuer tout de suite le bénéfice
pour 1,8 millions de retraités aux
carrières complètes mais aux pensions
les plus modestes pour leur permettre
d'avoir 670 euros de plus en moyenne
chaque année non nous ne nous
associerons pas à ceux qui ont pour
funeste slogan tout cramé ou révolution
nous ne rentrons donc pas l'émotion de
censure
nous nous laisserons pas entraîner par
une extrême gauche qui est assume de
vouloir détruire les institutions de la
Cinquième République nous ne serons pas
les témoins de ces noces barbares entre
ceux qui assument vouloir mettre le
chaos et ce qui silencieux n'ont aucune
proposition pour sauver les retraites
mais espère tirer profit de ce chaos
soyons clairs le problème aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas la réforme des retraites seul
président de la République
cette nécessaire réforme des retraites
payent 6 années d'un exercice isolé
parfois narcissique et souvent arrogant
du pouvoir comme insensible à la vie des
Françaises et des Français d'un pouvoir
qui a soit reclus à l'Elysée soit des
milliers de kilomètres le jour où je
recevais les syndicats d'EDF qui
m'exprimaient leur dépit face à
l'absence de dialogue du gouvernement le
président Macron était dans un bar de
nuit à Kinshasa quel décalage
nous regrettons cette méthode qui
confond volonté politique et absence de
dialogue social réel et sincère avec les
partenaires sociaux une méthode qui
laisse place un temps de revirement et
d'un cohérence ne vous étonnez pas que
des Français n'adhèrent pas à votre
réforme puisque le président Macron
lui-même il y a trois ans la critiquait
avec virulence le président de la
République n'a-t-il rien retenu de la
crise des gilets jaunes sans respect des
Français décor intermédiaires des
partenaires sociaux rien n'est possible
le bras d'honneur madame la Première
ministre n'est pas une méthode de
gouvernement
ce que n'importe quel élu local de notre
pays c'est du devoir d'écoute ou de
respect des Français le chef de l'État
semble ne l'avoir toujours pas appris
la crise que nous traversons c'est le
produit de 6 années de fracturation de
notre pays
on ne gouverne pas pendant 6 ans en
poussant par stratégie électorale les
électeurs de gauche dans les bras de
l'extrême gauche et les électeurs de
droite dans les bras de Marine Le Pen
sans que cela ne de conséquence
délétères sur l'état du pays une France
fracturée une France radicalisée une
France désabusée une France profondément
déprimée une nation en lambeaux
dans ce paysage dévasté elle est fille
et le RN ne sont que les jumeaux
infernaux d'Emmanuel Macron jouant
chacun à merveille sa partie de la pièce
et lui donnant la réplique espérée
je le dis très sincèrement
l'idée de rassembler dans ce pays les
patriotes de bonne volonté ceux qui
aiment la France et qui veulent la
reconstruire au-delà des clivages
pourrait être un projet pour l'après
Macron oui je fais partie de ceux qui
croient que notre pays méritera de
retrouver un jour vraiment l'esprit du
Conseil National de la Résistance qui a
su unir de façon certes éphémère mais
tellement décisive des gens aussi
différents que les communistes et les
gaullistes les socialistes et les
démocrates chrétiens mais qui avaient
tous en partage d'être républicain
ce projet ceux qui ont signé cette
notion de censure ensemble sont
incapables de la voir ensemble pour
répondre au défi de notre pays que
feriez-vous sur l'immigration vous
pensez l'exacte contraire les uns et les
autres que feriez-vous sur le
rétablissement de notre souveraineté
industrielle ou agricole s'il vous plaît
que feriez-vous pour redresser les
finances publiques et des services
publics d'un pays au bord de la faillite
que feriez-vous vous qui avez en commun
d'être incapable d'assumer la moindre
réforme pour contester il suffit d'être
virulent pour reconstruire il faut être
responsable courageux et cohérent
vous êtes tous en train de tirer le pays
vers le fond sans proposer de le
redresser
car le seul sujet au fond
c'est le déclin de la France
désormais au 25e rang mondial seulement
de richesse par habitant année après
année notre pays s'appauvrit et les
Français s'appauvrissent
la compétition économique mondiale sans
règles qui a tant fait s'ouvrir qui a
tant fait souffrir notre industrie et
désormais nos services et notre
agriculture à sa part de responsabilité
elle tire les salaires vers le bas et
affaiblit nos entreprises mais le poids
de nos prélèvements et nos pesanteurs
normatives en sont aussi la cause
dans cette France moins prospère les
Français regardent avec nostalgie ce qui
était la vie de leurs parents ou le
progrès social l'amélioration du niveau
de vie semblait promis à ceux qui
travaillaient ce n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui
l'effort est mal récompensé et la
solidarité trop souvent injustement
distribué voilà ce qui mine le pays la
politique d'Emmanuel Macron résolument
mondialiste d'une part et utilisant
l'argent public à tour de bras pour
tenter d'acheter la paix sociale d'autre
part n'a fait qu'aggraver se déclin
ne trompons pas les Français le
redressement demandera du courage et du
travail
oui
oui la France a besoin d'unité nationale
mais vous n'en êtes pas le chemin vous
n'êtes que celui de la facilité
le président de la République
entre les mains de nombreux outils
constitutionnels
il peut changer de gouvernement
il peut recourir au référendum il peut
dissoudre
[Musique]
soyons clairs il n'y a aucune offre de
notre part juste une demande le voir
exercer différemment son mandat à lui
d'entendre les avertissements y compris
le nôtre s'il veut aller au bout de son
quinquennat réformer oui fracturé non
je vous remercie monsieur le président
la parole est à monsieur le Président
Mattei pour le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues
aboutissement attendu du point de vue
institutionnel compte tenu de la
configuration de notre Assemblée
désormais ces motions censure sont une
somme de regret que je voudrais exprimer
ici au nom de mon groupe
oui nous avons des regrets notre premier
regret celui d'avoir jamais pu
pleinement examiner et voter ce texte en
première lecture alors que les deux
semaines prévues suffisaient à le faire
chers collègues de l'opposition en dépit
des règles de fair-play parlementaire et
plus encore de toute vertu démocratique
vous avez décidé de détourner notre
règlement pour créer une embolie
parlementaire motion
prise de parole identique à répétition
comportement empreint d'une forte
violence symbolique rappelle au
règlement et surtout plus de 20 000
amendements vous avez fait feu de tout
bois pour empêcher la tenue de nos
débats
tout cela dans un seul but empêcher le
débat et l'adoption même partielle de ce
texte en transformant l'Assemblée en un
véritable cirque qui fait honte à notre
institution avec
la présence pour finir
d'un responsable politique dans les
tribunes surveillant ces troupes comme
un empereur romain je n'ose imaginer ce
que serait une sixième république celle
que vous appelez de vos vœux
les députés du groupe démocrate aurait
voulu avoir le temps de présenter leur
point de vue qui nous semblait
équilibrer entre la nécessaire
responsabilité financière et l'objectif
de justice sociale vous nous avez privé
de ce débat et d'un véritable vote et je
le regrette amèrement parce que je sais
que dans l'intérêt des Français nous
aurions pu ensemble améliorer le texte
heureusement notre dialogue permanent
avec les sénateurs et notamment nos
cousins de l'Union centriste nous a
permis de défendre une large partie de
nos propositions et d'en faire adopter
un certain nombre Sénats puis en
commission mixte paritaire je voudrais
les remercier pour le travail que nous
avons su faire ensemble je crois même
pouvoir dire que ce travail en commun
illustre bien ce qu'est le centrisme
loin de l'intransigence dont font preuve
aujourd'hui certains qui sont réclamment
coeur mais l'ont en vérité abandonné
depuis de très nombreuses années
je voudrais aussi souligner la qualité
de nos échanges avec le gouvernement
même si toutes nos propositions n'ont
pas été reprises notamment celles
concernant le financement
notre second regret et le manque de
responsabilité de certaines oppositions
je ne parle pas de celles qui n'avaient
pas de projet si ce n'est de se cacher
derrière une forme de respectabilité
pour déposer à la fin une motion de
censure en espérant que personne ne
remarquerait leur absence de proposition
je ne parle pas non plus de ceux qui ont
défendu et voter en son temps 2013 une
réforme qui amenait les Français à
dépasser de plus d'un an l'âge légal de
62 ans sans le dire honnêtement et qui
défend aujourd'hui des propositions
totalement illusoires se raccrochant 60
ans croyant retrouver par ce totem les
grandeurs de 1981 et oubliant les grades
difficultés qui ont suivi cette
parenthèse enchantée
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas d'illusion pour cela même si
j'espère que nos concitoyens ne se
laisseront pas berner par ses miracles
je parle en particulier de l'opposition
qui avait promis depuis des années de
faire cette réforme des retraites c'est
la même que le gouvernement a défendu en
atténuant l'âge de départ par rapport
aux promesses de la candidate soutenu
l'année dernière par les par pays mort
la peur le jeu de billard les jeux de
billard à trois bandes et malgré tous
les efforts du gouvernement fait à votre
endroit vous n'avez pas voulu afficher
par un vol clair vos positions
divergence sur ce sujet qui aurait dû
nous rassembler même si je sais que
certains collègues du groupe les
républicains voulaient en responsabilité
votez ce texte
issu d'un compromis après un travail
sérieux et juste
nous voulions très majoritairement
groupe démocrate modem et indépendant
aller au vote de ce texte après
peut-être pour certaines et certains des
doutes mais surtout avec la conviction
que cette loi a été nécessaire et utile
nous prenons acte de la décision qui a
été prise de déclencher la procédure
prévue par la Linéa 3 de l'article 49 de
notre Constitution cet outil existe il
permet aux forces politiques qui sont
contre ce texte de le rejeter si elles
sont majoritaires
certains à cette tribune parlent de
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement comme un déni de démocratie
à mon sens c'est bien plus le
comportement de vos autres dans les mots
comme dans les actes qui frisent le déni
démocratie je voudrais d'ailleurs
rappeler que la queue de la violence
verbale ou symbolique à la violence
physique il y a souvent qui me parle
hop alors alors le groupe démocrate
alors le groupe démocrate prend acte
1 de cette inconscience acte de l'esprit
de responsabilité de responsabilité qui
anime le gouvernement et vous l'aurez
compris bien sûr soutenant le
gouvernement et persuadé de la nécessité
d'une réforme pour pérenniser notre
système de retraite nous ne voterons pas
cette censure mais il y aura un après et
de toute crise nous devons tirer des
leçons réfléchir au fond et à la méthode
ce que nous souhaitons profondément au
groupe démocrate modem et indépendant je
vous remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
président
la parole est au président Vallot pour
le groupe socialiste
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues
quoi qu'il en coûte à la démocratie la
réforme des retraites voulue par le
président de la République est un coup
de force politique elle n'est pas
seulement un impôt sur la vie de celles
et de ceux qui n'ont que leur force de
travail pour vivre elle symbolise comme
jamais sa pratique solitaire du pouvoir
qui pervertit la démocratie rend
possible son retournement en son
contraire impose ces volontés sans
discussion avec arrogance et mépris
mépris du débat parlementaire et du
dialogue social
mépris de la mobilisation syndicale et
de la volonté populaire mépris de
l'opposition majoritaire dès lors que
comme vous l'avez concédé vous-même le
compte n'est pas
mépris de l'intelligence des citoyens
quant à leur propre avenir mépris de
l'exigence du transparence de sincérité
et de vérité
quoi qu'il en coûte à la démocratie le
président de la République acculé votre
gouvernement et la majorité complice à
élever le mensonge les vérités
alternatives la falsification des
chiffres et la dissimulation des faits
auront d'arguments irréfutables de
réalité un discutable d'expertise
d'irréflugables il aura fallu lever 1 à
1 chacun de vos éléments de mensonges il
aura fallu aller chercher dans les
tiroirs des ministères les informations
que vous refusiez de communiquer au
parlementaire pire vous avez imposé une
logique or William qui fait mine
d'intégrer tous les points de vue afin
d'empêcher l'esprit critique de
s'exercer librement
vous soutenez le mensonge d'une réforme
de compromis alors que vous n'avez
dialogué en sincérité avec personne ne
vous êtes accordé avec personne n'avait
convaincu personne c'est une corruption
profonde du pacte démocratique qui exige
un minima le respect du contradictoire
c'est un coup de force contre la raison
et le sens commun qui plus qu'un
sophisme cynique est un véritable poison
aux conséquences incalculable au-delà de
ce projet de réforme au-delà de ce
quinquennat et je vous le dis au-delà de
vous-même
quoi qu'il en coûte à la démocratie le
président de la République a imposé
cette réforme au cœur d'une crise
sociale longue de 5 ans après la crise
des gilets jaunes qui dénonçait
l'asphyxie de l'injustice fiscale après
la crise de la covid la puissance
démesurée du mythe libéral la guerre en
Ukraine et revers d'une mondialisation
anxieuse vous acclablez en pleine crise
de la vie chère le sort des Français
ne le voyez-vous donc pas au
gouvernement ou sur les bancs de cette
majorité le pays souffre et le mal qui
la ronge c'est l'injustice nous le
voyez-vous pas la question qui nous
occupe ici et bien plus profond dans ses
sources et bien plus vaste dans ses
conséquences que votre seul réforme des
retraites
il ne s'agit pas d'une fièvre qui
pourrait retomber ce qui est en cause ce
n'est pas le destin du président de la
République ni l'avenir d'une première
ministre singulièrement absente du banc
des ministres durant ce débat sur les
retraites non la question qui nous
occupe est plus profonde et aura des
conséquences plus durables c'est une
révolte sourde contre l'ordre établi
c'est une quête du sens perdu du travail
de la place de l'homme de notre rapport
au monde aux choses et aux autres c'est
une aspiration que vous ignorez la
justice c'est une revendication que vous
refusez d'entendre le pouvoir de vivre
derrière nos éléments de langage d'une
réforme de progrès social derrière
l'autre cudence d'un ministre du Travail
capable de la prétendre de gauche mais
celui-là a tout oublié vous engagez à
marche forcée la précarisation des
seniors qui seront demain plus nombreux
au RSA à la SS et au chômage
vous taisez derrière ce projet
soi-disant juste et équitable que 60%
des économies se feront sur le dos des
femmes déjà grandes perdantes de notre
modèle économique c'est même femme qui
occupent en grande partie des métiers
pénibles les métiers du lien que vous
qualifiez hier d'essentiels et que vous
brisez aujourd'hui au détriment des
besoins d'une société vieillissante et
vulnérable vous dissimulez cette réalité
brutale derrière une préférente
prétendue réforme sont perdants vous
faites payer le quoi qu'il en coûte à
celles et à ceux que nous vasons nous
avons applaudis à 20h et qui espiraient
des échos de nos mains bien plus de
reconnaissance
à semer la misère madame la Première
ministre vous récoltez la colère quoi
qu'il en coûte à la démocratie vous
promettez une une retraite minimum à
1200 euros qui n'a jamais existé créant
la confusion et le mensonge et en même
temps vous remettez le partenamise
politique à l'ordre du jour en
considérant depuis des semaines que les
Français n'ont rien compris à votre
réforme alors qu'en définitive c'est
vous qui n'avez rien compris et ne
comprenait plus les Français
quoi qu'il en coûte à la démocratie vous
persistez et vous signez dans
l'hémicycle à la brutalité des fins
correspond désormais la brutalité des
moyens vous n'avez renoncé à aucun
détournement de procédure et disons-le à
aucun abus de pouvoir procédural après
avoir choisi un projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale après
avoir eu recours à l'article 47.1 qui
restreint les débats l'Assemblée
nationale puis aux orties 44 2 et 44 3
au Sénat pour étouffer la contradiction
vous dégainer le 49-3 le 11e de votre
législature votre méthode pour citer
monsieur Darmanin c'est le coup bas
permanent
madame la Première ministre
la démocratie expéditive est à la
démocratie ce que la justice expéditive
est à la justice ce coup de force
démocratique est une énième
manifestation du dédain pour
l'institution et les oppositions
parlementaires caractéristiques de votre
méthode
quoi qu'il en coûte à la démocratie vous
abolissez la séparation des pouvoirs car
son jésus l'Assemblée nationale aura à
peine débattu il aura en définitive
jamais voter ce projet de réforme des
retraites vous prétendez désormais
l'affaire adopter de la pire des
manières comme un décret loi ou comme
une charte royale octroyée à des sujets
disons-le tout net cette loi ne sera
couverte d'aucune onction démocratique
et parlementaire il n'y a pas eu il n'y
a pas il n'y aura pas de vote dans cette
hémicycle en faveur de ce texte les
représentants du peuple que nous sommes
nous l'aurons jamais adopté
[Applaudissements]
quoi qu'il en coûte à la démocratie le
président de la République
ignore de façon coupable les
circonstances de son élection et vous
même méprisez le parlementarisme de fait
issus des urnes et l'aspiration et la
démocratie continue des Françaises et
les Français au diable les si nécessaire
discussions sur la place du travail dans
nos vies les inégalités sociales et la
précarité l'emploi des seniors l'égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes le changement climatique le la
crise écologique
le front syndical est uni et déterminé
et quoi qu'il en coûte vous persistez à
l'ignorer et à les tenir en mépris les
portes même du président de la
République leur demeure obstinement
fermé et les ignorants vous prenez le
risque inconsidérés de disqualifier le
dialogue social et les organisations
syndicales et de laisser prospérer
partout dans le pays les formes les plus
désorganisées et probablement aussi les
plus brutales de la contestation la
mobilisation de la rue et massive et
quoi qu'il en coûte depuis des semaines
vous l'ignorez il en va pourtant de la
confiance dans la démocratie
représentative déjà si fragile est
toujours plus boudé dans les urnes il en
va du crédit qu'on accorde à celles et
ceux à qui les Français donnent la
charge de leur destin
il en va de ce fait de la voie que
collectivement vous pavés à l'extrême
droite désormais sans plus vous en
cacher au mépris du Front républicain
qui a élu le président de la République
madame la Première ministre votre
réforme est percluse de fausses
promesses et de vraiment songe vous
trouverez format juste et brutale n'a
pas de majorité elle n'a pas de majorité
dans le pays elle est la contre elle
toutes les organisations syndicales plus
des trois quarts de nos compatriotes la
rejette votre réforme n'a pas de
majorité dans cette assemblée retirez-la
ou si vous mettez là au suffrage des
Françaises et des Français et si vous ne
le faites pas nous le ferons à travers
un référendum d'initiative partagé
donnant la parole à celles et à ceux à
qui vous la refusez
quoi qu'il en coûte à la démocratie le
président se comporte aujourd'hui en
forcené en acharné enfermé désormais
dans un tête-à-tête avec lui-même ce
n'est pas du courage c'est de l'art et
des raisons retirer cette réforme il en
coûtera moins que votre obstination car
il en va désormais de l'intérêt général
de la concorde civile de l'avenir de
notre démocratie et quand tout s'écroule
je vous l'assure pour tenir debout il
faut bien plus qu'une paire de bottes
des députés socialistes et apparentés
votre ont cette motion de censure
transpartisanes et j'invite chacune et
chacun d'entre vous à la voté car elle
est un acte de foi dans une démocratie
parlementaire à laquelle le gouvernement
et le président en définitive ne croit
plus
le président de la République a fermé il
y a quelques années qu'il fallait aussi
les entre humilité et arrogance et que
si vous tombiez d'un côté vous deveniez
soit inefficace soit dangereux pour
réussissez dans cette réforme à devenir
les deux quoi qu'il en coûte pour la
démocratie
je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur le Président
Marc Angeli pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
nous sommes à un moment particulièrement
grave notre histoire commune sans
grandiloquence il faut s’émotions je
crois pouvoir dire que notre pays
traverse une crise de confiance sérieuse
dont le climat dans notre assemblée
témoigne clairement
cet après-midi chacun de nous devra
faire un choix en responsabilité
votez cette motion de censure c'est
faire tomber le gouvernement et ainsi
rajouter du désordre au chaos chacun des
membres de la représentation nationale
s'exprimera en son âme et conscience une
fois c'est fait rappeler j'invite tous
ceux qui qualifient ici un tel processus
de votre dictatorial à ôter leur filtre
idéologique et prendre un peu de recul
depuis le début de l'examen de ce projet
de loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale comme depuis le début
de la législature le gouvernement s'est
conformé à la règle de droit en premier
lieu la Constitution
que l'utilisation des outils du
parlementarisme rationalisé déplaise aux
oppositions c'est finalement assez
logique et je n'entends parfaitement je
vous rassure personne je dis bien
personne ne se réjouit du recours à cet
article 49 alinéa 3 parmi les
parlementaires ici présents qui sont
tout aussi attachés que vous à la
préservation des prérogatifs du
Parlement mais dire que cela constitue
un déni de démocratie ou une atteinte au
droit du Parlement après 175 heures de
débat est quasiment autant d'obstruction
nous ne pouvons pas l'entendre depuis le
début de la mandature l'opposition à
recours dans son bon droit aux outils de
procédure les plus spécifiques autorisés
par nos textes motion de rejet préalable
motion référendaire motion de censure de
tout cela le gouvernement n'est pas à
l'initiative pas plus qu'il n'est
responsable du refus de délibéré qui
nous a empêché d'examiner sereinement et
surtout d'aller au bout ce texte durant
la première lecture une réforme de
retraite est toujours une réforme
difficile mes chers collègues ici menées
dans un contexte délicat que personne
n'ignore mais ça n'en est pas moins une
réforme nécessaire nous sommes
confrontés à une réalité démographique
implacable et nous devons travailler
plus longtemps pour pouvoir y faire face
c'est un choix de société celui de ne
pas augmenter les cotisations sociales
ou de baisser les pensions même choix
qu'on fait tous nos voisins européens et
même dans notre pays je rappelle que
l'agir Carco organise de gestion
paritaire des retraites complémentaires
a fait un conseil identique à celui du
gouvernement en concertation avec les
syndicats il assume mesurer l'ampleur du
problème démographique et a pris des
mesures nécessaires pour assurer
l'équilibre de son système l'âge de
neutralisation de la décote a donc
naturellement été repoussée à 64 ans
nous ne sommes pas sourds chers
collègues nous entendons les
mécontentement et les inquiétudes c'est
parce que nous les entendons que nous
avons entrepris avec les sénateurs de
faire évoluer ce texte
c'est parce que nous les entendons
également que nous avons voulu faire
corriger ce système en faisant reculer
des inégalités vécues à l'heure où nous
débattons par des millions de nos
concitoyens car dans les faits
ce n'est pas cette réforme mais notre
système actuel qui est injuste ce que
nous proposons c'est une meilleure prise
en compte des situations des familles
une meilleure prise en compte des
carrières des femmes une meilleure prise
en compte des carrières longues la
valorisation de l'engagement des
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires et des élus
locaux et ce ne sont là que quelques
exemples ce texte ne prétend pas bien
sûr gommer toutes les injustices qui
existent elles sont nombreuses mais il y
contribue en dédiant 7 milliards d'euros
à leur réparation ce qui n'est pas
négligeable et c'est même plus d'un
tiers des économies générées c'est donc
une réforme courageuse qui a été décidée
par le Président de la République et
mené de front par le gouvernement et je
veux le dire très clairement le
traitement réservé dans cette assemblée
au ministre du Travail Olivier du sof
pendant les débats et à la première
ministre Elisabeth borne jeudi dernier
est inacceptable et indigne
non seulement
non seulement mes chers collègues cela
n'apporte rien sur le fond mais pire
encore c'est abîmé volontairement nos
institutions je tiens également à saluer
les députés de mon groupe pour leur
engagement au cours de cette réforme
l'un d'entre eux en particulier cette
illustré par un travail pointu et une
disponibilité sans faille je vais bien
sûr parler de Paul Christophe député du
Nord qui a été notre chef de fil sur ce
texte
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues nous avons devant
nous deux motions l'une d'opportunités
et l'autre partisane les deux peuvent
déstabiliser notre système démocratique
surtout les deux nuiront au système de
retraite et à sa pérennité car elles
auront pour conséquence de pousser à
l'emprunt illimité sur les marchés
financiers dont certains disent pourtant
vouloir s'émanciper notre mandat électif
nous oblige vis-à-vis des Français la
première de ces obligations c'est agir
en responsabilité et d'être responsable
en ce jour c'est rappeler qu'un pays
surendetté ne peut pas financer son
avenir prétendre l'inverse c'est
notamment mentir à notre jeunesse qui
aura assumé les conséquences de nos
choix par le vote de ces notions de
censure vous légitimez le comportement
des députés qui brandissent des
pancartes dans cette hémicycle eu le
gouvernement comme dans un stade couvre
la voie de la première ministre où font
encore mine de découvrir le
fonctionnement d'une commission mixte
paritaire à la fin de nos débats une
chose est certaine toutefois notre
assemblée si ce n'est l'ensemble de nos
institution et notre démocraties ne
sortiront pas indemne de cette séquence
les torts sont partagés des erreurs ont
été commises de parts et d'autres nous
devons nous livrer à une introspection
approfondie sur l'ensemble de ces bancs
sans exception je le répète cette
réforme est nécessaire et l'inaction est
un luxe que nous ne pouvons pas nous
payer plus nous payer mais la réforme
des retraites n'est pas l'alpha et
l'oméga de la vie de notre pays il nous
faut des à présent penser à la suite la
France est divisée nos concitoyens
inquièrent l'inflation la guerre aux
portes de l'Europe la brutalité du
changement climatique les problématiques
d'accès aux soins sont autant de sujets
majeurs dont nous devons nous saisir
pleinement surtout notre pays a besoin
d'être rassemblé et apaisé sans que cela
nous confère à l'immobilisme j'ai pour
ma part la conviction que nous devons
lutter contre les injustices autant que
contre le sentiment d'injustice ressenti
par de nombreux Français les travaux
lancés sur le partage de l'effort
devront guider notre action sur ce point
vous l'aurez compris nous avons besoin
d'un CAP qui permet à tous de se
projeter dans un futur serein et
ambitieux je sais que nous pourrons
compter sur votre engagement plein et
entier madame la Première ministre
pourrait parvenir c'est pour cette
raison que les députés du groupe horizon
y apparentés ne voteront pas ces deux
notions de censure je vous remercie
monsieur le président
la parole est à madame la Présidente
châtelain pour le groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mes chers collègues jeudi 16
mars 2023 constitue un point de rupture
la rupture entre un président et tout un
peuple la rupture entre un président de
la République qui a théorisé la société
des premiers de cordée et tout un peuple
qui depuis qu'il a fait la Révolution en
1789 recherche constamment obstinément
passionnément la réalisation de la
promesse républicaine de l'égalité
c'est au nom de l'égalité que les
Français se lèvent contre votre réforme
ne l'ignorez pas ne le méprisez pas ne
méprisez pas ces millions de personnes
qui ont défilé et qui défileront demain
encore soutenu par tout un pays ne
fermez pas les yeux elle a vu des
pancartes qui fleurissent un peu partout
en France et qui tant que bien que mal
quand de vous faire entendre raison
alors pendant quelques instants je vais
me faire le porte-voix de ce que vous
avez décidé d'ignorer il chante avec
Macron liberté égalité retraite mais
quand vous est décédé il chante encore
les précaires prêtres précaires ce n'est
pas un métier ou encore les profits des
milliardaires pour les vieux jours de
nos grands-mères et cela doit vous
rappeler d'autres mobilisations celles
des ronds des gilets jaunes du
ras-le-bol des travailleurs pauvres
souvenez vous elles écrivaient alors
taxons d'abord le kérosène gilet jaune
versus parachute doré la France d'en bas
contre la France d'en haut loin des
éléments de langage mécanisé ces
interpellations disent la diversité la
colère l'imagination du peuple unique
contre votre réforme ils jurent leur
désir de vie leur aspiration qui vient
au-delà de la vie et du travail elle
procame leur ras-le-bol face à ce monde
qui s'emballe pour lequel il faut
produire toujours plus consommer
toujours plus jusqu'à l'épuisement de
nos corps de nos vies et de notre terre
la Cour s'est freinée au profit
l'accroissement a fini de la richesse
pour quelques-uns la réduction de notre
travail à sa seule valeur marchande le
rétrécissement de chaque être humain sa
capacité de production c'est la France
ubérisée d'Emmanuel Macron une France
dans laquelle se creuse les inégalités
et où la société se fracture non la
France ne se résume pas à une simple
logique productiviste et financière la
France n'est pas et ne sera jamais la
start-up nation
ce qui fait la France ce sont ces
valeurs ce sont ses principes la justice
sociale la solidarité celle qu'ensemble
les Forces Républicaines françaises de
la droite gaulliste à l'ensemble de la
gauche ont su défendre avec le Conseil
National de la Résistance s'attaquer à
notre modèle à notre système de retraite
comme le fait le gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est s'attaquer au cœur de
notre modèle social pourquoi pour que
finalement pour financer les baisses
d'impôts pour les grandes entreprises et
pour qui pour de la vue du président
lui-même satisfaire les marchés
financiers la voici enfin la vérité
notre système de retraite n'est pas en
danger ni aujourd'hui ni demain non vous
voulez faire 18 milliards d'euros
d'économie sur le dos des 55 65 ans pour
diminuer aveuglément les dépenses
publiques au risque de mettre à genoux
notre économie nos démocraties et nos
modèles sociaux
ce que vous présentez n'est pas une
réforme c'est une aberration une
injustice faite aux femmes une injustice
faite aux travailleurs de plus de 55 ans
qui sont relégués aux marges du marché
du travail une injustice fait au
travailleuse des métiers pénibles qui
malgré la dureté de leur travail devant
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans une injustice
faite au travailleur qui triment avant
même d'être pleinement entrée dans l'âge
adulte derrière les carrières longues il
y a des vies passées à les gagner les
perdants de cette réforme ils sont
nombreux mais les sacrifiés se sont
toujours les mêmes les femmes grandes
sacrifiées de cette réforme Macron
premier avait déclaré l'égalité famome
grande cause de son premier quinquennat
et bien Macron second s'apprête à
creuser les inégalités entre les femmes
et les hommes
les personnes aux carrières longues sont
tout autant sacrifiées ces personnes qui
ne sont ni plus et moins que ceux celles
qui triment dans les métiers difficiles
peut rémunérer ce sont celles et ceux
qui ont les mains dans le cambouis
depuis qu'ils ont 16 17 18 19 ou 20 ans
ce sont celles et ceux qui fabriquent
les pièces détachées à Vesoul pour
Peugeot qui sont sur les chantiers des
Jeux Olympiques en ce moment même les
caissières du Super U ou ceux qui font
la plonge en cuisine ce sont eux et
elles qui tiennent la France debout ce
sont eux et elles que ce gouvernement
méprise
ignore
le président n'a pas perdu le contact
avec les Français de première ligne il
ne les a jamais croisés depuis les bancs
de ces écoles privées jusqu'à son
fauteuil dans les dans des banques
d'affaires il ne les a jamais croisés
alors ils pensent qu'il peut marchander
des trimestres en dans leur dos il pense
qu'il peut maintenir un âge de départ à
la retraite qui rend inopérant le
principe des annuités qui protégeait
ceux qui ont des carrières longues et
pourtant un travailleur qui a mis les
Bains dans le cambouis des 18 ans vous
le savez je le sais à une espérance de
vie bien moins élevée que ceux de la
plupart d'entre nous alors oui c'est
l'honneur de la représentation nationale
d'avoir débusqué vos mensonges c'est
d'avoir refusé d'être instrumentalisé
par un président de la République qui
oppose démocratie politique et
démocratie sociale c'est l'honneur de la
représentation nationale d'avoir su
entendre le front syndical affront
exceptionnel un front historique que je
salue depuis cette assemblée la CFDT la
CGT est faux CFE CGT la fftc l'une ça
solidaire la FSU lunaire Lafage la
fidèle voie lycéenne et le mouvement
national lycéen ce front syndical nous
oblige prenons garde prenez garde la
démocratie sociale n'est pas quantité
négligeable en démocratie elle est notre
lien indispensable au monde du travail
au travailleur c'est à dire aux Français
un lien aujourd'hui qui menace d'être
brisé enfin c'est l'honneur de la
représentation nationale d'avoir trouvé
le chemin d'une Concorde derrière le
groupe liotte que je salue d'ailleurs
pour exprimer le rejet de cette réforme
injuste et d'une méthode brutale
de la gauche à la droite de cette et
demi cycle nous sommes les représentants
des Français et des Françaises et je
citerai ici Paul Reynaud qu'il y a 60
ans débattait d'une autre motion de
censure il disait alors les
représentants du peuple si décrié
aujourd'hui ça vient qu'ils ne sont
prises de l'aimant que des
portes-paroles modestes précaires
faillit vilipendait souvent mais ils
savent aussi qu'ensemble ils sont la
nation et qu'il n'y a pas d'expression
plus haut de la volonté du peuple que le
vote qu'ils émettent après une
délibération publique madame la Première
ministre en utilisant le 49 à Linéa 3
décidée par celui qui se rêve Jupiter ce
n'est pas seulement la majorité dans
cette émission qui vous fait défaut
c'est l'immense majorité des Français
qui vous tournent le dos
alors certes un grand renfort d'éléments
de langage vous nous rappelez que oui
vous nous piétinez mais en toute
légalité mais voilà ce qui est légal
n'est pas forcément légitime vous auriez
tort de ne pas vous soucier d'adosser
vos actions à la légitimité populaire
une élection présidentielle a fortiori
celle de 2022 n'est pas un blanc sain à
gouverner et à réformer contre 75% des
Français ces élection présidentielle à
laquelle vous faites référence
constamment comme pour masquer le manque
de majorité dans cet assemblée cette
élection ne vous autorise pas à
maltraiter des institutions et à faire
en quelque sorte un nouveau de bras
d'honneur à l'Assemblée nationale cette
élection par défaut aurait dû vous
conduire à la recherche constante de
compromis avec les oppositions mais
surtout oui surtout avec les corps
intermédiaires la légitimité électorale
est un socle mais elle ne se suffit pas
elle-même un gouvernement ne peut
gouverner tant qu'ils ne dispose tant
qu'il dispose d'une approbullition
populaire d'une adhésion politique d'une
confiance dans son action aujourd'hui
vous n'avez plus aucun des trois sans
cette confiance sans la profonde
certitude que la décision du
gouvernement que les décisions du
gouvernement sont prises avant tout dans
l'intérêt des Français et jamais pour
des intérêts particuliers sans cela vous
ne pouvez rien faire à un moment où il y
a ton passé la sainte les synthèse du
dernier rapport du GIEC publié
aujourd'hui nous exhorte à réduire
immédiatement drastiquement nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre pour
limiter le réchauffement climatique sous
2 degrés planifiez la bifurcation de
mode de vie et de production est
indispensable cela ne sera pas facile
mais cela sera impossible si c'est fait
sans justice et par un gouvernement qui
ne suscite que défiance et colères vous
avez plongé la France dans une prise
politique profonde transformée une crise
sociale en une crise de régime vous
n'avez plus les moyens de gouverner un
pays qui a pourtant besoin d'engager des
réformes structurelles pour affronter la
crise climatique environnementale vous
n'avez plus les moyens de gouverner un
pays qui est rongé par la défiance
depuis la gilets jaunes vous n'avez plus
les moyens de gouverner un pays où les
températures augmentent et où les pluies
ne sont plus et ou demain les
travailleurs du BTP travailleront sur
les toits sous 50 degrés au soleil vous
n'avez plus les moyens de gouverner un
pays qui s'enfonce dans une spirale
inflationniste et qui fracasse les plus
vulnérables c'est pourquoi madame la
Première ministre les écologistes
voteront sans la moindre hésitation
cette notion de censure nous ne pouvons
pas nous permettre un gouvernement sans
légitimité qui n'aura pas les moyens
d'agir
je vous remercie madame la Présidente
la parole est à Monsieur Pierre
Daredevil pour le groupe GDR
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers et chers collègues
une colère
pas un coup de colère
encore moins une vague de désapprobation
une profonde colère
quelque chose dans l'ordre de la révolte
même le refus sans appel de la
régression sociale le refus de se voir
voler deux de ses meilleurs années de
retraite le sentiment de ne jamais
pouvoir être entendu le sentiment d'être
pris pour des imbéciles le sentiment de
ne pas être respecté l'idée que ça
suffit tout simplement
on ne méprise que les gens qui font des
choses méprisables écrivit Alberto
Moravia
qu'on fait les ouvriers les employés les
privés d'emploi pour mériter tant de
mépris qu'on fait les organisations
syndicales qu'on fait celles et ceux qui
manifestent pour mériter tant de mépris
qu'a fait notre peuple pour mériter tant
de mépris
car c'est ainsi que vécu votre politique
c'est ainsi que vécu votre entêtement
c'est ainsi que son vécu votre discours
et vos justifications toujours plus
embrouillées c'est ainsi qu' est vécu le
49-3 car ce n'est pas seulement à cette
assemblée qu'il a été infligé c'est au
pays tout entier je monte à cette
tribune tremblant de cette colère de
cette résistance épidermique au mépris
de cette attachement viscéral à la
dignité humaine la dignité c'est bien
cela qui est en jeu voilà ce qu'on m'a
demandé de vous dire ces derniers jours
dans les quartiers sur les marchés dans
les villes hier soir le président a
exprimé son souhait que la loi aille au
bout de son cheminement démocratique il
faut arrêter de se moquer du monde je
vous le dis comme je le pense avec
respect car du mépris je n'en ai pas
mais avec colère avec combativité avec
franchise je me demande
comment vous pouvez être encore là à
défendre votre réforme scélérate qui n'a
pas de majorité dans cette assemblée qui
en a encore moins dans le pays votre
réforme est définitivement illégitime et
vous vous trompez lourdement si vous
pensez que vous pouvez vous en tirer
comme ça que c'était juste un mauvais
moment à passer que tout ça sera bientôt
oublié ce n'est pas le caprice d'un
enfant à la caisse du supermarché votre
projet est grillé vous avez perdu la
bataille des retraites
je ne veux même plus vous redire à quel
point votre projet est scandaleux
injuste injustifiable inégalitaire
régressif attentats au monde du travail
et douce heureux pour le monde de la
finance je ne veux même plus vous redire
à quel point nous sommes attachés à ce
droit à une nouvelle étape de la vie
opposée à votre projet de société
centrée sur le profit sur la personne
humaine compétitive et rentable réduite
à produire et à consommer vous voulez
faire de nous des hamsters dans leur
roue qui rongent leur vie et leur
planète je ne veux même plus vous dire à
quel point vous avez été démasqué sur le
diagnostic à quel point vous opérations
de publicité mensongère ont été
ridicules à quel point tout le monde a
bien compris votre volonté d'affaiblir
le droit solidaire à la retraite par
répartition un tel changement ne peut
exister sans être consenti la seule
chose à dire c'est que cette réforme
quoi qu'on en pense doit être retiré
d'une manière ou d'une autre vous avez
perdu à chaque étape à chaque étape vous
êtes passé
et ce n'est parfois de vous avoir alerté
de vous avoir appelé à la raison à la
lucidité à la responsabilité vous auriez
pu faire de cette épreuve un moment pour
réparer pour rassembler pour apaiser
vous auriez pu montrer la grandeur de la
démocratie et de la République et bien
non vous avez choisi de placer des
engagements comptables au dessus de la
volonté populaire vous avez choisi de
placer la satisfaction des intérêts de
la finance au dessus du bien-être social
au-dessus du respect du travail au
dessus du droit mérité à la retraite
Emmanuel Macron l'avait dit la belle
affaire nul ne lui a confié les pouvoirs
dans mon arc absolu votre responsabilité
n'est pas d'exercer un pouvoir sans
limite vous n'exercer de pouvoir qu'au
nom du peuple c'est avec lui que vous
devez gouverner et non pas contre lui
quel pays prétendez-vous gouverner
comprenez-vous ce qui est en train de se
passer la crise politique gravissime
dans laquelle nous nous trouvons à peine
un tout autre comportement qu'une
attitude autoritaire suffisante
paternaliste arrêtez de nous dire que
vous faites ça pour notre bien c'est
insupportable ne faites pas le par du
pourrissement et de la répression plutôt
que d'entraîner le pays dans cette
régression sociale dans cette tension
dans cette crise vous auriez pu initié
des dynamiques pour s'attaquer avec
beaucoup plus de force aux effets de la
vie chère à la faiblesse des salaires à
l'urgence culturel au malaise
démocratique à l'affaiblissement de la
fonction publique au défi climatique au
drame de la guerre vous avez tant
sacrifié pour mener à terme votre
mauvaise réforme et les projets que vous
annoncez nous inquiète au plus haut
point parce que vous voulez continuer
dans la même veine à remasteriser la
France en effaçant le meilleur de son
histoire pour imposer les canons du
néolibéralisme qui défait la République
et son pacte social ou donc emmenez-vous
ainsi le pays vous pouvez toujours
pointer les responsabilités des autres
la vôtre est écrasante nous avons
entendu les petites manipulations pour
se rattraper aux branches cette notion
tiendrait lieu de vote sur le texte ce
vote vous en avez privé notre assemblée
parce que vous alliez le perdre vous
avez perdu cette notion renverrait ce
texte d'où il n'aurait jamais dû sortir
mais désormais la question va au delà la
gravité de la situation provoquée par
vos choix vous placent dans l'incapacité
de continuer à conduire la politique de
la nation chers et chers collègues par
delà les mesures elles-mêmes chacune et
chacun c'est bien ici que ça ne peut pas
continuer comme ça ne vous racontez pas
d'histoire ne cherchez pas d'excuses ou
de justification libérons ce
gouvernement de ses responsabilités
c'est notre responsabilité de
parlementaire c'est notre responsabilité
de lui demander de partir avec sa
réforme sous le bras ne pas le faire
c'est d'abord accepter que cette
mauvaise réforme demeure alors de du
jour ces deux ans de plus voulez-vous
les imposer ne pas le faire c'est aussi
approfondir la crise démocratique et la
crise institutionnelle la crise de la
République mesurer la fracture mesurer
la blessure mesurer les effets c'est la
confiance dans la République et dans la
démocratie qui est fragilisée
des institutions de la 5ème République à
bout de souffle mérite d'être refondé
pour nous permettre de mieux décider
ensemble au regard des exigences de
notre temps nous devons faire la
démonstration que la volonté populaire
peut se frayer un chemin nous devons
faire la démonstration que le Parlement
écoute et agit nous devons faire la
démonstration que la démocratie n'est
pas une pétition de principe c'est bien
cela qui est en jeu au de la même des
retraites ou de la même du sort d'un
gouvernement et nous voulons saluer ici
l'action résolue rassembleuse
prometteuse des syndicats de ce pays
celle des militantes et des militants
engagés dans l'action collective au sein
de leurs entreprises alors même que
depuis tant d'années les forces
dominantes ces forces de les
marginaliser de mépriser leur
revendication de limiter leur pouvoir et
essaye de décourager les femmes et les
hommes de se mobiliser et d'espérer
c'est avec eux avec elle que se joue la
victoire les mobilisations populaires
dans notre pays ont provoqué conquis
accompagner les plus belles avancées
sociales et démocratiques notre
assemblée doit trouver des issues tracer
respective et il faut pour cela produire
des gestes quel gestes d'apaisement de
respect de compréhension ont été
produits par l'exécutif ces derniers
jours aucun le sens de notre motion est
clair elle veut porter l'espoir
d'améliorer le droit à la retraite pas
de le réduire elle veut porter l'espoir
d'une alternative politique heureuse
elle veut battre en brèche les projets
dangereux anti-égalités anti fraternel
de l'extrême droite qui est sans
solution pour nos retraites notre motion
veut mettre un grand coup de frein à la
frénésie des politiques libérales et de
la loi de l'argent elle appelle à mettre
à l'ordre du jour les belles choses qui
sont dans les têtes et dans les cœurs
aux ouvriers des ports de la sidérurgie
de la pétrochimie ou des champs aux
employés de la SNCF d'EDF aux caissières
aux agents territoriaux aux Atsems aux
aesh aux enseignantes et aux enseignants
aux aides-soignantes aux infirmières aux
artisans et commerçants à celles et ceux
qui exercent des métiers pénibles mal
reconnus à celles et ceux qui se battent
pour la justice qui défendent un vrai
droit à la retraite partagée un travail
qui prend tout son sens et pas toute la
place où l'on s'épanouit à ces femmes et
ces hommes à cette jeunesse pleine
d'espoir nous disons que rien n'est fini
et que nous avons le droit de continuer
à rêver plus fort et plus haut et si le
vote de cette motion devait décevoir
nous disposons encore d'outils pour nous
faire entendre nous avons déposé un
recours et une proposition de référendum
d'initiative partagée qui devrait être
validée pour montrer que nos
institutions ne sont pas complètement
inopérantes face à une telle crise
démocratique alors nous irons partout
débattre et chercher les signatures par
millions pour imposer une sanction
démocratique à cette réforme
la bataille se poursuit dans les
mobilisations sociales et notamment avec
cette grande journée de jeudi prochain
c'est contre cette réforme
pour que vive le droit à la retraite
pour le respect de la volonté populaire
pour sortir de la crise au nom de la
République que les députés communistes
et ultramarins de la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine sont actrices et acteurs
d'une motion de censure
je vous remercie mon cher collègue
la parole est à monsieur Adrien catenin
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres collègues le temps est
suspendu à cet instant et comme rarement
dans nombre d'endroits du pays de la
maison au café du coin des lieux de
travail à la rue les regards sont
tournés vers notre assemblée la Maison
du Peuple de par la présence des
représentants qu'il a élus on nous
écoute on nous regarde on attend avec
espoir le résultat de notre vote sur
cette motion de censure car dans
quelques minutes si 287 d'entre nous le
décident la volonté de deux tiers des
Français et de renvoyer ce gouvernement
et son injuste réforme des retraites
peut devenir une réalité en République
il n'y a qu'un seul souverain c'est le
peuple tout entier et non pas le
président de la République enfermé dans
son palais or depuis le début de ce
quinquennat comme ce fut tant de fois le
cas dans le précédent cette souveraineté
populaire a été censuré il y a moins
d'un an alors qu'il venait d'être élu
Emmanuel Macron se disait conscient que
les Français avaient été nombreux à
voter pour lui au second tour davantage
contre l'extrême droite que pour son
programme il ajoutait que ce vote
l'obliger qui est donc devenu cet
obligation censurée la réponse des
Français ne se fit pas attendre puisque
le président de la République a été
battu par la nupes au premier tour des
élections législatives et que la
majorité présidentielle n'en est
désormais plus une la première ministre
c'était alors présenté devant notre
assemblée sans solliciter le
traditionnel vote de confiance des
députés et depuis quelle sort est
réservé au vote des députés censurés en
dégainant le centième 49,3 de l'histoire
de la Cinquième République vous en êtes
à votre onzième soit 1/493 tous les 28
jours en moyenne depuis le début de ce
quinquennat et on l'utilisant pour une
réforme injuste et brutale à laquelle
s'oppose 93% des actifs du pays vous
l'avez plongé dans une crise politique
majeure c'est en fait une crise de
régime les liens spasmes de la
lentagonie de cette cinquième république
des sens monarchiques à bout de souffle
de tiers des Français souhaite
l'adoption de cette motion de censure
2/3 des Français souhaite votre départ
madame la Première ministre deux tiers
des Français souhaite que le mouvement
contre la réforme des retraites se
poursuivre mais parce que sous les
lustres dorés des plafonds de l'Elysée
un homme seul et toujours plus isolé
souhaite rhabiller un passage en force
en processus démocratique ce sont deux
tiers des Français qui devraient être
censurés cette réforme des retraites n'a
aucune légitimité parlementaire aucune
en l'utilisant un véhicule législatif
inadapté un budget rectificatif vous
avez contraint les deux chambres à
débattre dans un temps limité et
empêcher assemblée de se prononcer en
première lecture même au Sénat où vous
aviez la majorité vous avez eu recours
au vote bloqué et ici à l'Assemblée un
énième 49-3 pour empêcher le vote des
députés le vote de cet après-midi doit
donc remettre les pendules à l'heure
rappeler le président et son
gouvernement à la réalité être en phase
avec les aspirations populaires vous
prétendez que cette réforme est la seule
solution pour notre régime de retraite
par répartition c'est votre préférence
politique certes mais il y en a bien
d'autres et les Français le savent
d'autant mieux qu'il voit une petite
minorité se gaver toujours plus sous les
effets de vos réformes pendant que le
grand nombre souffre et que les fins de
mois difficiles commencent dès les
premiers jours 10 millions de pauvres
dans le pays record d'Europe des
versements de dividendes ou 5 personnes
possèdent autant que 27 millions vous
dites que c'est pour le bien du peuple
qu'il faut parfois aller contre sa
volonté mais le massif des Français avec
votre réforme et le recul de l'âge de
départ à la retraite n'est pas un
caprice de mal informé voilà donc
plusieurs mois qu'ils utilisent tous les
recours démocratiques possible pour
exprimer leur désaccord la grève si dur
et si chère des manifestations massives
à répétition dans un calme que vous avez
vous-même salué des syndicats unis comme
rarement et de votre côté le coup de
force permanent après avoir sacrifié
deux années de vie de tous les Français
contre leur volonté qu'avez-vous
l'intention de faire contre celles et
ceux qui ne baisseront pas les yeux
devant vous les coups de matraque les
gaz lacrymogènes la genèse du pays à
genoux les mains sur la tête votre
obstination est en train de mettre le
pays à feu et à son sous le regard de la
presse internationale qui découvre
parfois que la France est un simulacre
de démocratie parlementaire où
l'exécutif peut gouverner seul contre
tous le retour au calme c'est la
démocratie
sinon la solution c'est le peuple
interroger le don par référendum et quoi
qu'il en soit à vous tous qui nous
entendez par de la semure prenez la rue
dès aujourd'hui
par la rue
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
Deschamps des hurlements des Invincibles
des pupitres qui claquent voilà le
spectacle auquel se sont livrés jeudi
dernier certains députés
dans un déchaînement de violence comme
cette émission en a peu connu sous la
Cinquième République
certains élus de la nation ont une
nouvelle fois montré le peu de cas qu'il
faisait du débat du Parlement de la
démocratie
ce n'était pas un fait isolé
c'était le paroxysme de semaine entière
durant lesquelles au cœur même du
Parlement nous avons vu l'anti
parlementarisme à l'oeuvre sous toutes
ses facettes
nous avons vu la nupes déployée avec
méthode constance et détermination toute
la palette des techniques d'obstruction
dans le seul et unique but d'empêcher le
débat
nous avons vu le mépris de nos
institutions s'afficher sans le moindre
scrupule jusqu'à qualifier la commission
mixte paritaire de prise d'otage
nous avons vu
nous avons vu claire aussi dans le jeu
de ceux qui méprisent cette assemblée et
veulent récolter les fruits du chaos le
mutisme de l'extrême droite ne trompe
personne jeudi dernier d'ailleurs le
naturel a repris le dessus à coups
d'attaques personnelles et de crise
effrénées
mesdames et messieurs les députés cet
après-midi intervention après
intervention j'ai constaté en écoutant
certains orateurs qu'il n'y a décidément
pas de limite à la duplicité
ce sont les mêmes qui ont tout fait pour
saboter le débat à coup d'amendement
dilatoire de cris et d'insultes qui
viennent nous reprocher de ne pas avoir
pu suffisamment débattre
ce sont des élus de la nation qui
viennent nous expliquer sans vergogne
que 175 heures de séances plus que pour
les deux précédentes réforme des
retraites ne valent rien ce sont des
députés qui déni son rôle au Parlement
et affirme que la rue est plus légitime
que les institutions
mesdames et messieurs les députés ces
comportements sont graves ils sont
graves car il ne s'agit plus de
s'opposer avec force mais d'empêcher la
discussion et de couvrir coûte que coûte
la voie de l'orateur qui ne partagent
pas vos idées comme si toute parole
contradictoire était insupportable
ils sont graves car pour certains toutes
les outrances toutes les violences sont
permises
ils sont graves car ils constituent sous
le regard des Français aux deux extrêmes
de l'hémicycle une remise en cause
directe et frontale de nos institutions
de notre constitution de notre
démocratie
la haine et la brutalité ne devraient
pas avoir leur place dans le débat
parlementaire car si l'on ne peut plus
débattre à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
le fonctionnement même de notre
démocratie qui est empêché
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs les députés comme
vous j'ai été élu il y a près d'un an
comme vous je vais à la rencontre des
Français dans ma circonscription du
Calvados et surtout le territoire
je parle
[Applaudissements]
je parle avec nos concitoyens de leur
doute de leurs inquiétudes de leurs
espoirs personne sur ces bandes a le
monopole pour parler au nom du peuple et
j'ai bien conscience de l'état d'esprit
de notre pays
[Applaudissements]
je sais les interrogations et les
inquiétudes que cette réforme soulève
j'ai conscience de l'effort qu'elle
demande à bon nombre de nos compatriotes
je mesure la mobilisation d'une partie
d'entre eux dans les mouvements sociaux
cette réforme le président de la
République s'est engagé à la menée lors
de la campagne électorale certainement
pas pour gagner des voix mais par
exigence de transparence vis-à-vis des
Français
[Applaudissements]
c'est d'abord par responsabilité avec
gravité humilité et conscience de la
sensibilité de l'enjeu que l'on s'engage
dans une réforme des retraites
bien sûr les constats sont connus
l'impasse démographique et le creusement
des déficits mais ce ne sont pas des
arguments d'autorité et personne
n'imagine que la seule réalité des
chiffres atténue l'impact de la réforme
pour celles et ceux qui devront
progressivement travailler plus
longtemps mais alors il faut être clair
sur les alternatives
certaines ont été présentées par des
amendements dans cette émission elles
peuvent se résumer en deux mots
matraquage fiscal ce sont des impôts et
des charges de supplémentaires
qui pèserait sur le pouvoir d'achat des
Français et menacerait leurs emplois
l'autre chemin que certains proposent
c'est l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation
mais alors il faut dire la vérité aux
Français pour équilibrer notre système
de retraite par répartition il nous
faudrait travailler 45 années en
transparence que ceux qui la proposent
où l'on proposait assume les
conséquences d'une telle mesure pour un
titulaire du BTS d'un BTS qui a commencé
à 20 ans cela voulait cela voudrait dire
une retraite à 65 ans en responsabilité
nous n'avons pas fait le choix des 45
ans
[Applaudissements]
oui mesdames et messieurs les députés
pour concevoir cette réforme avec le
ministre du Travail Olivier du soft nous
avons pris le temps de regarder toutes
les propositions et de modifier les
nôtres les mois de concertation avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
auront permis d'aboutir à des avancées
importantes sur le texte je pense à la
prise en compte de la pénibilité aux
carrières longues ou encore aux
carrières incomplètes notamment des
femmes au risque de surprendre aux
extrêmes de cette émission le débat et
la concertation c'est utile
je veux également saluer le travail mené
depuis des mois par les parlementaires
des trois groupes de la majorité
présidentielle Renaissance modem et
horizon
devant le défi des retraites vous avez
fait des propositions importantes
innovantes dont beaucoup sont reprises
dans le texte final devant le vacarme et
les insultes vous n'avez jamais dévié du
cap du débat et face aux outrances vous
avez montré le visage de la dignité
démocratique
devant les échéances vous ne vous êtes
pas laissé intimider vous avez pensé à
l'intérêt général à la préservation de
notre modèle social plus qu'à vos
destins personnels
[Applaudissements]
ce ne sont pas vos voix qui ont fait des
faux et si j'ai dû recourir à l'article
49-3 de la Constitution ça n'est pas du
fait de la majorité qui elle d'un bloc
était pleinement mobilisée
mesdames et messieurs les députés les
mois de concertation en amont du texte
les propositions de la majorité et des
oppositions et les 175 heures de débat
au Parlement auront permis d'aboutir à
une réforme équilibrée porteuse de
progrès et qui prend au mieux en compte
les situations de chacun
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui c'est sur votre texte pas
sur le projet du gouvernement mais bien
sur le compromis trouvé par le Parlement
que j'engage ma responsabilité
rejetez ce compromis ce serait financé
nos retraites par la dette et fragilisée
dangereusement notre système par
répartition
rejetez ce compromis ce serait privé 1,8
millions de retraités modestes d'une
augmentation de leur pension dès la
rentrée une augmentation en moyenne de
600 euros par an
rejetez ce compromis ce serait privé les
professions libérales d'une pension
majorée de 10% à leur troisième enfant
je pense notamment aux infirmières
libérales
rejetez ce compromis ce serait continué
à demander à ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 16 ans de continuer 45
années pour toucher une retraite à taux
plein
rejetez ce compromis ce serait renoncé à
investir un milliard d'euros pour
prévenir la pénibilité des métiers non
notamment pour ceux qui portent des
charges lourdes ont des postures
pénibles ou accomplissent des gestes
répétitifs
rejetez ce compromis ce serait renoncé à
des mesures qui réduiront d'un tiers les
écarts de pension entre les femmes et
les hommes
et je veux saluer tous les
parlementaires qui ont entendu l'appel
des Français au travail conjoint et ont
participé au-delà des clivages avec le
gouvernement avec la majorité à bâtir et
améliorer cette réforme des retraites
mesdames et messieurs les députés se
débats sur les retraites soulève des
réflexions plus larges sur les
évolutions de notre rapport au travail
sur l'égalité des chances sur les
perspectives que l'on peut offrir à
chacun avec mon gouvernement je veux
répondre à ces défis déjouer les
déterminismes sociaux assurer l'accès à
de vrai parcours professionnels et
améliorer la qualité de vie au travail
face à ces enjeux je reste convaincu
qu'il n'y a qu'une seule méthode
chercher des compromis et ne jamais
renoncer à l'action
dans les jours dans les semaines et les
mois qui viennent de nouveaux textes
seront débattus au Parlement il n'est
jamais trop tard pour sortir des
postures mais quand je vois une motion
de censure signée par toute la gauche
mais avec comme figure de proue un
partisan de la retraite à 64 ans comme
le proposait monsieur le député de
Courson votre amendement en octobre 2013
attenant
[Musique]
attenant historique de l'austérité
budgétaire un opposant notoire au
mariage pour tous et qui n'a pas voté
l'inscription de l'abolition de la peine
de mort dans la Constitution
alors je constate alors je constate que
la nups
quand elle est prête à toutes les
compromissions quand il s'agit de
chercher le blocage
plutôt que de construire des alliances
baroques pensons à l'intérêt de notre
pays plutôt que de former des blocs
contre travaillons à bâtir des majorités
pour
mesdames et messieurs les députés dans
les jours les semaines et les mois qui
viennent pour répondre aux
interrogations des Français nous devrons
aussi ouvrir une nouvelle page de notre
démocratie sociale je suis convaincu que
le dialogue social doit être la norme
qu'il doit précéder chaque projet je
suis même convaincu que sur beaucoup de
sujets la bonne méthode est de
transcrire dans la loi les accords
trouvés avec les partenaires sociaux
c'est d'ailleurs c'est d'ailleurs avec
la majorité ce que nous vous proposerons
de faire prochainement sur le partage de
la valeur
mesdames et messieurs les députés
mesdames et messieurs les députés avec
cette réforme nous ne sommes jamais
allés aussi loin dans la construction
d'un compromis
[Applaudissements]
le gouvernement a pris toutes ses
responsabilités
mais les aventures individuelles les
positionnements tactiques et la crainte
de l'impopularité n'ont pas permis
d'assurer une majorité
cependant comme il se doit la démocratie
parlementaire aura le dernier mot c'est
elle qui a permis de forger ce texte de
l'améliorer de l'enrichir par des
propositions de l'Assemblée nationale
comme du Sénat des propositions de la
majorité comme des oppositions
c'est la démocratie parlementaire qui a
permis d'adopter ce texte par deux fois
au Sénat et lors d'une commission mixte
paritaire où le gouvernement n'était pas
présent et ses soutiens n'étaient pas
majoritaires
c'est enfin la démocratie parlementaire
qui s'exprimera par votre vote
l'article 49-3 de notre Constitution qui
permet au gouvernement d'engager sa
responsabilité et au Parlement de la
censurer à une histoire précise garantir
au Parlement de ne pas sombrer dans
l'impuissance comme cela avait été le
cas sous la Troisième puis la Quatrième
République
[Applaudissements]
ceux qui déguisent le 49-3 en un outil
antidémocratique on la mémoire courte
ils oublient que c'est justement
l'affaiblissement du Parlement et
l'incapacité à légiférer dans les
situations de crise qui a conduit
certains à remettre en cause la
démocratie parlementaire voir la
démocratie tout court dans les périodes
les périodes sombres de notre histoire
le 49,3 n'est pas l'invention d'un
dictateur mais le choix profondément
démocrate qu'a fait le général de Gaulle
et qui a approuvé le peuple français
car à la fin il y a un vote nous sommes
au terme du cheminement démocratique et
politique de cette réforme si vous
voulez renverser le gouvernement qui la
porte vous en avez désormais la
possibilité je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre
la discussion comme une éclose
[Applaudissements]
je vais maintenant mettre vous à la
motion de censure déposée par Monsieur
Bertrand pencher et 90 membres de
l'Assemblée le scrutin est annoncé dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale je
rappelle que seuls les députés
favorables à la motion de censure
participe au scrutin et que le vote se
déroule dans les sales voisines de
l'hémicycle le scrutin va donc être
ouvert pour 30 minutes il sera clos à 18
à 18h45 la séance est suspendue
mes chers collègues je vous demande de
bien vouloir regagner vos places la
séance est reprise voici le résultat du
scrutin majorité requise pour l'adoption
de la motion de censure sur la majorité
absolue des membres composants cette
assemblée 297 pour l'adoption 278 la
majorité requise n'étant pas atteinte la
motion de censure n'est pas adoptée je
veux mettre maintenant en voile la
motion de censure déposée par Madame
Marine Le Pen et 87 membres de
l'Assemblée le scrutin est annoncé dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale le
scrutin va être ouvert pour 30 minutes
il sera clos à 19h20 la séance est
suspendue
[Musique]
mes chers collègues la séance est
reprise voici le résultat du scrutin
majorité requise pour l'adoption de la
motion de censure sur la majorité
absolue des membres composant
l'assemblée 287 pour l'adoption 94 la
majorité requise n'étant pas atteinte la
motion de censure n'est pas adoptée
aucune des deux motions de censure
déposées n'ayant été adoptée le projet
de loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 compte tenu
du texte de la commission mixte
paritaire modifiée par l'amendement
déposé par le Gouvernement et considéré
comme adopter